the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
time is quickly ticking away at the st
louis rapid and blitz with only two days
remaining blitz masters look to gain
ground and valuable points
blitz legend hikaru nakamura lived up to
his reputation storming up the standings
racking up six wins without a loss to
land in clear third the only performance
as impressive was alareza faroujas who
nearly matched it winning five without
losing to increase his stranglehold on
the lead there's only one day left can
the french phenom be stopped the final
day at the saint louis rapid and blitz
coming up next
[Music]
welcome back everybody to the final day
of the saint louis rapidan blitz this is
it the championship day the day where a
victor will be crowned who's going to
make the final push and win the saint
louis rapid and blitz title let's go to
the studio and find out with yasser and
peter
live from sunny st louis the home of
chess in america we welcome you to day
five of the saint st louis rapid and
blitz the fourth stop of the 2022 grand
chess tour
welcome
hello peter
welcome is welcome yeah can barely
contain my excitement and i really am
very excited for this because this this
has been a very very interesting
tournament so far no question and it's
been really really fun to call as well
hello everyone and uh welcome to our
live coverage thank you for sharing your
day with us well after four
days of play
we do have a clear leader one alireza
farrugia
but it was also the rise of hikaru
nakamura in yesterday's rounds of blitz
that caught our attention peter do the
honors where do our current standings
like let's take a look
alareza is on 18 out of the possible 27
points as you can see they're in very
very safe position three points clear of
maxima graph and importantly three and a
point three and a half points clear of
hikaru nakamura who had a fantastic day
yesterday with uh seven and a half out
of nine three drops and six victories
uh but we shouldn't really forget about
maxim because
i i checked and uh maxim actually was
the person who scored eight out of nine
in zagreb a few months back so he's very
capable incredibly capable of scoring uh
unbelievable amounts of points in in in
blitz so this could still become uh
quite interesting if reza perhaps
stumbles against his direct competitors
but for now of course he sits very
pretty there three points clear of the
field he certainly does in our format
peter
the format is we play round robins we've
already played two a rapid one over the
first three days and a full blitz round
robin yesterday today we play another
one with colors reversed the time
control will be uh five minutes per game
with two seconds after increment after
each move draw for is not an issue
people have been not really in the mood
for drawings not at all and the scoring
system as you can see rapid games are
behind us in in the blitz games we have
the standard one point for a win and
half a point for a draw today is the
last day uh what's our schedule for
today
well nine games of blitz and then we
started we start very very soon and
there will be a closing ceremony after
the potential tie break if that happens
there's definitely a
type of treatment to the regulations
absolutely wonderful crowning of a
champion indeed
and christian
excuse me uh nice to see you in studio
my friend you're gonna drill down and
tell us about our leaders
it's good to see you guys it's great to
be back in the studio for this final
championship day we've had a fantastic
event so far and what a day of blitz we
had yesterday incredible results all
throughout but let's take a look at who
the shining stars of this event have
been and especially from yesterday of
course it's ali reza firuja who took the
lead after day one and never let go of
it while yesterday he had an amazing day
of blitz and that allowed him to build a
significant lead at the top of the
standings just an incredible results for
this young man five victories and four
draws absolutely no defeats but there
was another story in the tournament and
that was the pineapple shirt man
grandmaster hikaru nakamura who
unfortunately for him had the subpar
performance in the rapid bliss but he
was angry yesterday in the blitz section
super focused and did not lose a single
game won six games and i have to
highlight that draw in the eighth round
against jan nepomnyashi while the
pendulum swank so many times in that
game he was winning losing then he was
getting checkmated on the board but in
the end he managed to survive well right
now only three and a half points behind
the leader anything can happen when this
guy is playing over the board and let's
take a look at the grand chess tour
standings as we enter this final day of
blitz well we know wesley so is not
playing in this event because he already
played three events he's leading right
now with 22.5 but closely behind with 19
points is maxim vascular graph who if he
finishes well clear
not necessarily clear at the top but
close to the top he will be able to
surpass wesley so in that first position
and of course we have to highlight ali
reza first 12 and a half points but if
he manages to win first place seoul
first place and get those 13 points he
will jump all the way to 25.5 needless
to say we're going to have an amazing
day filled with fast and furious blitz
action and there we see our leader
taking a seat getting ready for this
round
10 of blitz action again just to repeat
what you said peter it's a round robin
everybody will be playing everybody with
colors reversed from yesterday and tell
us
about this uh round ten peter let's take
a look uh we have yanni pony she playing
uh white against alireza that's got to
be our marquee matchup look at that wow
that's a goody that's a good one uh
fabiko's head up on a different
tournament so far i would say is white
against hikaru uh jeffrey shang is white
against lebanon onion uh mvl is white
against uh shakira mundarov and lanier
dominguez is playing against sam
shankland uh the two players had a
really really poor day yesterday and
would very much like to return to uh you
know normal form because they both
played way way below what we know they
are capable of they certainly did
now lavon sporting as always i'm very
very nice shirt there he
looks to be in a decently good mood
and lots of fighting chess uh absolutely
which we're
grateful for and what are they fighting
for peter
let's take a look at the prize fund the
price fund for rapid english events on
the tour is uh constant at 170 75 000
dollars
indeed with a 40 000 uh going to the
victor and 7 000 to the person finishing
in last place and as you can see there
christian has already spoke about the
gst points but yet there is there's
plenty on offer there before the final
events of the summer which will begin
two days after we're done here the
sinkhole cup which will decide the end
oh uh
we're back for pineapple express
how many of those does he hey
well uh we're we'll see what's it worth
now
as we uh came in the studio and uh the
top three players for ruja as you just
pointed out mbl capable of scoring eight
out of nine he's done it hikaru equally
capable
we're gonna see some massive scores we
could we could
whenever in particular and in that
tournament where mvl scored eight out of
nine yes
and there hasn't made one other draw in
the tournament so they basically scored
like half the points in play it seems
like on that last day in zagreb with
with mbl getting eight out of nine and
there is a seven and a half but those
those do feel like freak occurrences and
they they shouldn't really happen every
time these guys sit down the field is
extremely tightly packed in terms of you
know skill and racing and
things of that nature but we'll see on
yesterday's forum both hikaru and
henri reza could just continue cutting
you know cutting the field in the field
in half right christian i'm used to two
horse races how about you a three horse
race today i would say a three horse
race yes uh definitely if icaru would
have had just one extra half a point i
would consider uh him well not
necessarily close behind alireza but
definitely much more manageable to get
those three points three and a half
that's four uh decisive results and
unfortunately for him i don't think
that's going to be enough i have to say
alireza's has such a commanding lead
right now only a miracle would allow the
other players to catch up to him you'd
have to stumble badly but it's very easy
to stumble badly
when your opponent is nepo and amir with
the white pieces the mvl
type scoring yeah eight out of nine in
the last day and well that's going to
put a lot of pressure on algebra i
wonder if we will finally see the the
king's gambits come out because
he's had decent success with it i think
he's beaten alireza in an important game
in the king's game i think that that may
have been online but nope
d4 no no kings gambling no kings can be
today yeah another catalyst
yeah open catalan
yeah alerts are going for arguably the
most solid line against the catalan and
currently in existence
which is a bit uh you know saddening for
us because this will be an end game from
from move seven onwards but it's still
heavily theoretical black doesn't really
equalize every single time in these
lines we have all of us have seen
white get
uh a pull a pull there yeah but uh
this being round one of the day there is
just no way
alireza is doing this unprepared
uh so yeah you you would assume he'll
get a playable position out of the
opening here how deep uh christian does
the analysis go in this very topical
very very deep and i remember i think it
was a game from the american cup between
ray robson and sam savion and they
played like 20 plus moves of theory and
then sam savian made a very very slight
inaccuracy and got into a completely
losing position so there's still a lot
of nuances and details that black has to
be aware of to fully equalize at this
end yeah and the position we have on the
board right now looks like a kind of a
boring end game the most popular move in
this position has seen a hundred games a
hundred years so the the total number of
games in this position is uh way above
100. uh the main move here is knight ft4
which is what uh
jan does well availing himself of the
opportunity to perhaps play knight b5
next and i think after okc8 by far the
main move here is knight b5 uh trying at
least to get a
a bishop pair by trading uh the bish27
foreign knight on the g6 square i see
um
yeah this is this is all steel extremely
extremely well known you you you
mentioned that uh with very accurate
play black equalizes blah blah blah
it's like
you know
why does black have to suffer
to make draws i think the argument here
is that maybe you don't have to suffer
very much if you know what you're doing
and jan actually deviates from that and
goes rook ac1 instead of knight b1 a
move which uh instead of knight b5 yeah
it's an id5 yeah uh a move of which uh
anish geary has played up ages ago
actually i thought i was i i immediately
assumed it was a recent game by by niche
but no it's a it's an old game from
2013.
uh but it's it's a very rare move it's
so almost
non-existent compared to 95. remarkable
such an obvious move developing the
pieces
maybe a crucial tempo exactly
despite its appearances i think it's a
very very uh tempo-oriented position and
uh you often will not have uh
time to just uh you know play quiet
sensible
yeah i'm not sure exactly what this is
because jan is
right this moment i think is one of the
one of the best prepared players in the
catalan i think he
throughout this tournament he's been
showing
a great wealth of ideas and all kinds of
catalans so this is clearly not random
but
it also doesn't really look like much i
mean once again we see this move h4 that
he has against icaru in the rapid
portion as well but what if yes knight
takes d4 which was played on the board
and then just simply get out of dodge
with the move b6 how are you going to
continue how are you going to develop
anything in the position as white
yeah i'm really unsure about this i even
the immediate b6 also looked playable
but yeah and now we can play bishop b8
was not the only movie you can just go
ahead and take on d4 and then play the
movie absolutely yeah
absolutely
uh
this looks like black is uh getting into
a very i don't know i don't want to get
too destructive but it looks to me that
maybe jeffrey shong is a piece up right
now after one minute against against
lavon against levon yeah oh my goodness
but also we know that nepo is so well
prepared nevertheless he spent already
two minutes
off of his clock and alireza is actually
ahead on time so maybe he just uh
misremembered some of his lines it's
possible but
it is such a well-known position that
sort of not playing knight b5 i think
your hand just makes that move
automatically right
um
he actually stopped to think but
it still seemed like by far the most
natural option and what he's doing here
like it really should not be giving
anything at all to white we can play
bishop a4 follow it up by knight g7
pieces will just start coming off it it
it feels very very level
exactly maybe four plate i expect e3 to
support the bishop on d4 if you allow c4
c5 maybe you will be slightly worse best
of circumstances but after knight g7
we're not really allowing c4 c5 so
no um
it it looks like it's just going to be
or rook c8 and gd rook c8 might be also
very very well that stops c5 altogether
because pardon me bishop takes b3 uh
just simply wins upon
um
we by the way we might be missing
something but
he's actually saying that black is doing
much better right now i wanted to say
why don't we simply prefer black in this
position yeah and c5 yeah this looks
like that's not desperate well not
necessarily this brother you just want
to simplify the position well it's it's
a pawn sacrifice uh quite simply yes so
you take on b3 take on b3 you have to
take with the pawn because and then b3
before i assume actually does make a
draw just bishop takes f6 right yeah i
mean but also i think this probably is
fine for white if we're if we're
entirely honest with ourselves we don't
lose very many of these what if i go
with c4 now c4 i wanted to play b5 and
claim that a7 is somewhat weak and i can
play bishop c6 next move and
uh attack the uh yeah and this mission
is actually on the board let's see what
other other things i mean black is that
can play 97 and of course
you're entirely safe yeah but i don't
think you win very many either
yeah i think the two bishops compensate
for the pawn quite well in the in these
types of positions but yeah a very very
strange uh first game here by uh by yan
who but by the way guys jan could have
taken on c5
which just wins a pawn in a very clean
fashion you cannot take with the knight
because i have e5 and you resign bc5
instead of bishop takes b3 ah that was
just that might have been much close to
winning you have to go bishop b2 or
knight d2 which are
moves that you don't yeah that is that
actually is war showing because bishop
to xb3 is such an obvious move but
actually bc5 is just much stronger
because knight c5 e5 loses a ton of
materials yeah yes on spots oops
nepo's whole play in this game has
really not been worth emulating i'm not
entirely sure what's going on here he
will now have to uh suffer a little bit
for the draw rook c7 played by the reza
bishop v5 bishop d6
uh
yeah you can just take on d7 and it will
be a opposite color bishop ending which
you pretty much never lose or you can
exactly you can look for better for with
white but i don't think you actually
need better
this is at this point bailing out is
probably your your best option no i was
wondering i was wondering if there is
something to worry about in that
position but i don't think so i think
it's just a draw bishop b7 rook c7 and
d4 yes you lose the pawn on d4 after
bishop b6 but that doesn't really matter
at all no it does not it's just a very
comfortable draw
well uh for ali reza you something must
be going through his mind too it's like
why are these guys seizing
uh slightly worse positions against me
as white and then fighting their way to
a drop bishop bishop too jan actually
does want more he wants to take on d7
comfortably next move and take on c5 but
i mean knight b6 exists i'm not quite
sure why we're
not just liquidating into a completely
completely equal position this is this
this has been a weird game i will say
this has been you know not much
optically not much is happening but
there's a lot of subplots in there and
they're all kind of weird yeah not
favorable to jan at all
you're keeping your eye on some of the
other games christians yes
caught your attention i heard jeffrey
was a piece about that
it's completely winning fabiano and
hicaro are still having a very balanced
uh game and uh it seems like mvl
unfortunately for him he's in a much
worse situation against mamedyarov with
the white pieces that could potentially
be a big result but let's now get back
exactly here we could take a look at uh
at our players and uh knight b6 on the
board and jan quickly
yeah rook given b7 b5 he is gaining some
space but after rook's rookie bishop a6
we can still sort of discombobulate
those pieces right and then we will take
on c5 play rook c1 as i said the two
bishops on a more or less completely
empty board provide so much coverage
that you don't really run that many
risks true despite you know black has
minus power black has an extra pawn on
on the a file
an actual outside passer but yeah i
don't think jan loses this but why is
this even a conversation we're having
it's arguably the safest line of the
catalan you can imagine right it's a bit
beyond me yeah exactly so i'm
anticipating because
rookie seven we take take we go bishop
b8
uh he doesn't even want that he's
claiming he's better despite being upon
them he's definitely not wars but i
don't know he's better yeah rookie seven
bishop d4 yeah you i mean white is
completely fine but this is the second
very easy draw that he
he said no to him
uh if if clock was a factor i would be
saying like i understand why white is
keeping
uh the play going but i don't think
the clock favors
nepo not not really it's sort of easier
to play with the bishops here and i'm
not in love with the idea of playing h6
if i'm entirely honest with you yeah g6
yeah why didn't we play h5 and g6 is uh
yeah i'm not sure in order to play
bishop g7 and kind of force bishop takes
b6 but then again i mean he is a pawn up
and
threats will be very very difficult to
come by as you can see uh once again
young could have taken on b6 twice yeah
he says he's just not worse and there's
absolutely no reason for him to to force
anything yet to try to actually make
sure he has a draw
i think ali reza's some moment is saying
you better take on b6 otherwise i'll
play rook d6 again i think the position
is even better just completely yes i
agree too uh with that uh yeah and there
we go okay finally finally finally he
says okay you've convinced me i have to
do this now nvl by the way seems to have
saved that position against mamedyarov
and yeah very very important in the
context of parliament yeah right
yeah
ah draw
yeah draw you kind of see it saw kind of
a slice yeah with the rook
with the rooks on you can sort of
pretend maybe but yeah with the rooks
coming okay very good let's jump to that
nakamura game or let's jump to the
jeffrey zhang game because uh he is
after all a piece up for two pawns
but c5 is definitely
with the entire game switching to to one
side like if in the blitz game if the
queens come off
you can maybe make an argument this
becomes a somewhat tricky technical task
and the queens might actually come off
because queenie won't check yeah okay
one i think you actually just take on c1
and i think this is yeah this is your
best bet you know the pawn will fall
even though currently you have bishop d3
followed by c4
but yeah i think that there must have
been a point somewhere earlier in the
game where jeffrey could have just not
allowed not allowed any of this because
you do actually fail to win this
sometime some percentage of the time
with
with two against four and uh in
particular if levon could find a way to
put like his uh
uh pawns on on good squares on the king
side
what are the good squares on the king's
side i wanted f6 g5 h4 would be the the
ideal setup but
uh we have not gotten there
f6 g5 h4 yeah but now
yeah jeffrey established this kind of a
setup where you know he isn't i'm not
sure about the 5 check
i'm really not sure about a 5 check i'm
also not sure about king h6 i would have
put it on f7 uh
in a heartbeat
and then perhaps played g5 check myself
i don't know but uh
i don't like anything of uh what
jeffrey's doing myself i just
what is the king doing on h4 why isn't
it on
e4 yeah i'm not yeah i'm not
convinced by by this technique
knight e7 yeah
now my king is trapped on h4
yeah this is all very confusing because
yeah you you will like any any progress
now is very much connected i think with
giving up the pawn on f5 and then
drawing chances
no no if you've only got one left
that is only got one left on g3 i think
you just kind of don't win
wow yeah i think i think lev is about to
get away with it yeah remarkable yeah
very very a couple of uh times during
this event we've uh seen the extra piece
not necessarily g5 check why we're not
playing g5 g5 checking membership sound
check and then king g6 but okay this is
still fine i think well the whole
problem is white's king remains trapped
you're going to have to play g4
which puts it the pawn on the light
square which allows us to keep bishop
just a draw yeah just to draw now
by the way somehow he cuts a huge better
position yeah that's something we should
switch to that let's jump to that one
it's wow well such reduced material but
like you say hikaru suddenly has won a
pawn yeah he comes out of nowhere
completely out of nowhere
i three check g takes e3 is also check
it check check
yeah
and it looks like there's a check from
behind there knight to d1
and there is a g pawn
whoa
we are extremely unhappy about this as
white because despite only 27 freeing up
the f3 square for tonight knight f3 is a
threat right now this looked like a very
very safe end game and suddenly it
became okay
g5 knight f3 is the problem knight f5
bishop c8 bishop d5 let's go i'm not
sure we were supposed to trade bishops i
think bishops came off i think two
against one is almost always a draw if
you play it
reasonably precisely but i mean it's not
a fun draw to make but it's pretty much
all yeah g3 knight h4 is a yeah it's a
draw now because knight h4 and yeah g3
we can take you can think right no you
can d2 check
this is getting scarier
this this i did not really enjoy this
might actually just be losing yeah
e33 and he lost on time as well he lost
his car keeping
keeping up the pressure no i don't think
we could have taken with the ball on g5
we could have taken but with the ball on
g6 i think black has enough time i think
he's gonna lead down to three points
guys hicary was in second position
was at three going into today but the
the gap between the two has been
narrowed to three points i've been told
that mvl was losing draw draw draw draw
and only hikara winning well what
happened how did
shaq led mvl off the hook mbl was in
seconds let's take a look at that one
indeed so it was just about this time
i think c takes d4 yes this end game was
very very unpleasant from
white's perspective rook to c8 queen to
d5 this exchange and now black is just
simply enjoying an extra exchange he
should be able to convert this one
nevertheless you still have some
technical tasks ahead of yourself
because this e pawn is such a powerful
resource for white and this is exactly
what happened
allowing the knight to get centralized
like this with knight c3 knight takes d5
was the wrong way to do it and actually
black lost a couple of tempest he should
have attacked the pawn structure with
the move g5 earlier on now unfortunately
for him after e6 it just becomes quite
clear that this e pawn in cooperation
with the knight and the bishop as well
will be able to create a lot of
unpleasant trees in against black's
position e7 rock three a bishop to c5
knight to c7 of course he's coming you
don't have time to go bishop to a5
because b4 would arrive on the board and
actually running after out of squares
for your pieces so after king to f7
which was played knight to c7 this is
just a a draw so he escaped i have to
say mvl and let's take a look by the way
guys this game between jeffrey and
aronian jeffrey was winning as early as
move let me just give you the exact
number i think it was move 12. this was
the critical position if you play bishop
to e7 followed by castle this is just
going to be a normal a situation in the
opening he played the move bishop to d6
and now you're just simply not in time
to cover all your pieces i go e4 which
he did and you don't have time to play
castle and stop me from going e5 castle
rook to e8 if you do try to uh stop it
with the move knight to e5 well the
bishop is on d6 so the queen is
overloaded queen takes b7 rook takes d6
this is just game over right so you
cannot do that you cannot stop me from
playing e5 and he did not he played
castle e5 and this is just a piece up
this was a piece up at move 16 and
unfortunately for jeffrey he was unable
to convert that end game that we just
watched and uh caruana versus uh hikaru
hikaru was building up a very nice
advantage out of the opening
and if you are watching this show please
stop challenging me on a new test
because we're seeing all these
challenges here i know i know you want
to be on the show all right queen to e3
king to h1 queen to c5 knight to f5 g6
knight h4 queen uh here this was the
critical moment after rook to f2 black
should have not allowed white to play
the move c4 and close things up on this
side he should have went ahead and go
with the move c4 forcing almost pretty
much to move d4 but this position after
bishop to g4
you do have some sort of a nice center
nevertheless this center is going to be
easily tackled by my pieces rook to e8
maybe even bishop to c8 followed by
bishop to uh b7 to focus on the e4
square it does seem like black is just
enjoying a much better position but
let's take a look at where it all went
wrong all the way in the end game it was
a very very easy it seemed like a dead
draw right i couldn't think of any other
result about the draw in this position
king to f2 knight to h7 sure the king
has activated and the knight on h7 is a
little bit misplaced nevertheless
there's still not enough resources to
create anything more uh than just a
tickle against white's position king to
e5 knight to f8 bishop to e8 now i'm
tickling your pawn on g6 and this was
the critical moment take take knight to
f6
in my opinion he should have went with
the move knight to f8 knight f6 still
keeps the equality on the board
nevertheless it passes the initiative to
black's hands because after c4 take on
c4 bishop take c4 you're starting to
need to make uh only moves in order to
equalize
you have to defend this pawn on e2
somehow if you do go with the move king
to f2 which was played king to f4 and
now you have to defend the position with
a pawn down and let's take a look at the
flag in this game two seconds for
fabiano one second still a losing
position at that point knight to f3
well that was a couple of milliseconds
too late and that was it hikaru nakamura
well gets closer to the leadership
position thank you for that uh christian
um peter
we are of course in st louis the chess
capital at the capital of chess in the
united states and 50 years ago
there was a match there was a world
championship match in reykjavik
uh
iceland that changed
everything history you could you could
argue everything but i think you should
take the lead there as a representative
of the winning side
in that competition allow me the honors
thank you so much yes everybody in 1972
bobby fischer
challenged boris baskey in what was a
clash that just
riveted the entirety of not just the
chess world itself but the entire world
it was front page news
around the world and very much so here
in the united states i was a part of the
generation that got caught up swept up
in a bobby fischer mania and the world
chess hall of fame is featuring an
exhibition that has
tons of really really really cool
archive material
and the exhibit is simply marvelous
peter yes i i
took a chance to
stroll a stroll across that hall and
take a look at some of the things
on display there it's a really really
interesting exhibition i probably will
return and because we were in a hurry at
the time and i would like to spend maybe
half an hour just
going going through everything in that
hall properly there you see a facsimile
of the
the chairs and tables
that
the match was featured upon again you
know front page news all kinds of
exhibits
photos
by
i wanted to say
the name just escaped me for
uh yes harry benson a very very famous
photographer
recreating the scenes
starting starting from bobby's childhood
and going all the way to to the match in
in 1972 and even beyond with the some
before never seen materials so yeah if
you're if you're in st louis uh and
interested in chess history at all
yes you've got to go this is something
that is absolutely not to be missed it's
a tremendous tremendous exhibition for
me
something that i would never forget was
this concept that bobby fisher
became a chess grandmaster at 15 years
old in my mind that was just like like
staggering it would never ever ever
happen that anybody would ever break
this record it would be there till the
end of time a boy was i wrong on that
one
records do exist to be broken exactly
but uh again if you're anywhere near st
louis do make an effort to go to world
chess hall of fame and here are our
standings after one alireza's still
leading as you can see but hikaru now
caught up to mbl per second 15 and a
half and also a bit of a personal
milestone i want to mention not to jinx
anybody but with that victory over uh
fabiano corona who is also a very well
established 2800 player in blitz right
hikaru is now uh 0.6 points away from
the magical 2900 so that is to say he's
28 94.
99.4 99.4
so uh
one more win yeah a win in round 11. he
will get him gets him gets him across
whoever he plays yeah speaking of round
11 that's coming up very very shortly
shall we take a look at the pairings and
figure out our marquee matchup
alireza is playing against jeffrey with
the white pieces mvl is playing against
fabi uh levon plays white against hikaru
not the easiest game actually to break
the 2900 barrier for
yvonne is a pretty decent blitz player
and there's also somebody who i think
generally plays well against kikairo and
then we have mamijarov against dominguez
and shankland against nipomnishin
nakamura is starting with two blacks
christian and if he gets through
two blacks with two wins
uh he will have the bit between his
teeth what do you think of that and then
he plays furuja in a direct encounter in
a bit of a teaser for around 12 for you
for your dear viewers yeah in round 12
we know which game we're watching right
that will be he gets he gets the white
pieces against alireza and that will be
absolutely perhaps a tournament defining
game if hikaru manages to win that and
alternatively if alireza comes out ahead
he probably puts the whole thing more or
less safely to bed because the the gap
is still
very very wide between him and the rest
of the film sorry i'm not sure i got
your marquee match up are you going to
go with the youths no i think i think we
have to watch the person on 2899 i think
you think levon versus
the hikaru uh is that history in the i
mean because you have such big swings
you mentioned eight out of nine by mvl
people breaking the twenty nine hundred
barrels
before i don't think this happened i'm
not sure but i have a feeling this will
be the first time this the the that
record will have been broken there you
see a very
nice uh shot of uh the players just
chit-chatting they seem to be very happy
with each other yeah it's so it's a
comfortable group of people they all
they all have been around each other for
ages and ages and i think most of them
are on very good terms with each other
absolutely um
and by the way these players that are
going to be meeting next round aronian
versus cicarus they started off the
blitz competition head to head in terms
of live blitz ratings 28 50.
right now i think levon might actually
be close to being under 2800. no no
levon is 2845 he improved oh he improved
yeah he improved he had he had a poor
start but he started off
he's only losing four points of racing
after ten ten rounds of blitz so it's
it's not that bad alireza is in third by
the way reza wasn't in this picture at
all and he is now on the live list 20 38
so he is he's gaining 43 points just
fine he's losing yeah and fabiano is
uh is losing losing rating for sure yeah
yeah and by the way since we do have
time i
i did find this very cute moment in this
game between dominguez who is really
struggling in uh this event but after
this draw he actually
well equal equalized his score from
yesterday's rounds half a point out of
nine this is going to be half a point
out of well let's see how many queen to
a1 was the move that shanklin played in
this position and after e5 d takes e5
queen to e4 king to g7 a very cute motif
in the position queen takes e5 was
played in the game and that actually
allows the transition into more or less
an equal end game but a really nice move
which create a suzwang situation rook to
d3 if you move this rook you no longer
keep touch with the pawn on f2 so i will
be able to play uh rook to c6 i don't
have to worry about the f2 pawn anymore
and you're going to get checkmated you
also cannot bring back your queen into
play because after this move to d3 i'm
controlling both the d1 and the d4
square
if you do go queen to b1 then you're
losing the pawn on e5 and that's going
to come at tremendous cost for the
safety of your king and if you do go
rook to f6 or rook to f5 anywhere on the
f file you're losing the c7 pawn so it's
basically a seuss one with so many
pieces still on the board a very cute
motif and of course after king to h8 you
might be looking and saying that yes you
cannot go rook to c6 i'm safe you cannot
keep touch with the pawn on h6 but rook
to d3 not only that it limits the
mobility of your pieces and of the queen
in particular but also it creates this
setup with rook to d2 defending the pawn
on f2 with this rook and now i'm ready
to jump with the other rook to c6 that
is the entry square in the position
that's going to create havoc around the
king this would have given white
dominguez a clear advantage very very
cute moment in that particular game that
was beautiful rook to d3 rook to d2 very
in an unexpected zug's run yeah no but i
have to say that queen a1 really looked
awful i'm not sure i'm not sure why it
went there yet but really
you can sort of stumble upon it by by
playing g3 and then looking for a good
move of the king h8 but in general uh in
a blitz game those things are
very sophisticated very very difficult
to uh to play uh just a quick moment
about yesterday's play because it
actually confused us uh
um shakriar has made his put his king
into check
and resigned the game after is after it
was pointed out by nepo nepo didn't
capture the king say you can't do that
and
shaq folded
but
illegal moves do not lose peter the
first one doesn't lose and what we
didn't appreciate and what was later
told to us by by the friend of the show
and the arbiter of the gct david cedric
uh
and i also separately yan told me in the
evening uh
uh that's a whole story yeah we we only
started watching that end game uh from a
very very late in the game and
apparently this was this wasn't the
first illegal move in the game prior to
that moment uh shah who perhaps was not
having the best 10 minutes of his life
also played knight g8 g7 which is a
it's a that's not a question these are
the rules either
there are chess variants which include
the piece called the giraffe okay and
you have a light square giraffe on b1
and the dark squares giraffe on g1 and
they go
three up and then one one to the side
right all right so that he made the
giraffe move which is like
admirable but not allowed
so it was the second illegal move of the
same game that cost him the point i
think he also just resigned out of
just sheer sheer embarrassment exactly
i'm not sure he knew he lost the game by
then he just thought okay i mean this is
this is two this is two in one game i'm
probably not expected to continue from
here anastasia asked him by the way
uh after that illegal
double illegal move you know like what's
going on and
shaq just couldn't recover you know as
you said the embarrassment was too great
uh and at last a
yeah yeah glory be who knew that we
would be begging for berlin and
not glory rookie one uh
yeah let's let's just wait until they
they get somewhere here because yeah
well i don't think either of us
particularly wants to discuss the
intricacies of move orders in the berlin
i will say that bishop d7 h6 and king c8
is i think a very very heavy indication
there by higaro that he is playing for a
win
because you know as far as berlin's go
after knight c3 and move 9
king 8 followed by h5 is
you know the way to make heavily
theoretical but reasonably well
researched by this point draws and
hikaru knows them really really well so
that would that would have been
a way to try to equalize the line that
he is playing is a lot sharper it is it
leads to much more double age positions
which is i think what he wants because i
have a feeling that i mean winning the
tournament for him would you know take
precedence of course but he is i suspect
keeping a bit of an eye on that live
raging thing right
so no question yeah so he knows that a
win here will at least you know get him
over the hill you know in terms of live
raging i just have to say that lavon
this line of play for black will not
come as a surprise for lavon i remember
an absolutely beautiful game that
lavonne won on the black side against
juan godikamsky
in a very crucial competition so he
knows that the double and i'm also
thinking
of the
the match in chennai the world
championship match uh
pardon me between magnus and uh
and um
vichy
uh which featured uh this very
double-edged line
also with g7 g5 so
we've got a good fight going we'll see i
think in general the setup with b6 king
c8 has been uh kind of popular maybe 10
15 years ago it's
i wouldn't say disappeared but the top
player is popular the the top players in
general i think very much moved towards
just playing king eight h5 learning
those lines making those draws and just
you know moving on with their life but
uh not what hikaru wants out of this
game today peter one bad piece for white
the knight on c3 what's it doing there
do you want to put it on
[Music]
f4 i think or do you want to play it on
e4 and just set
and also there's
and there is d5 yeah there's also d5
which i think uh is uh definitely an
option and g5 i think will be almost an
immediate reply after 95 because okay or
the inclusion of all of this yeah and
the trader pieces the pieces disappeared
of our screen very very quickly that was
a kind of a jolt wasn't it and this is
this is why i think lebron is doing this
because by including the check and
taking on a8 he is now attacking the
pawn on c7 meaning that black is not in
time to play g7 g5 and stop now and stop
that yeah knight f4 uh christian
over to you what's caught your eye
we'll we'll wait we'll wait for that for
a second yeah i think levon probably is
reasonably happy with this outcome
because if you have to play let's say
king b7 knight f4
and
i mean allowing knight takes e6 is not
no that's not great we're playing for
bishop e7 yeah
and the way not to do it is to play
bishop c8 which also really doesn't look
right bishop c8 uh playable yeah
how
yeah i that is an unfriendly pin no no
in particular because the way to unpin
yourself for black would be to play g7
g5 but that runs out yeah that is an
issue immediately five or six issues
right so but you wanted to also to throw
an e5 e6 yourself it's sometimes yeah
it's sometimes quite useful just to play
six here and we do have bishop c8 on the
board it's interesting kikara is being
extremely provocative here because yeah
inviting both rook d8 as well as e6 yeah
and he has to because in fact alireza is
uh having a tremendous position against
jeffrey and might win another game
well hikaru doesn't know that but right
he generally has to i mean he knows he
has to play for a win in every single he
needs to win a lot of games yeah he
needs to win a bunch of games in this
tournament to have a any shot of
of chasing alireza's score and by the
way on the topic of uh best ever scores
in the gct uh the record belongs to
magnus carlsen who won the calcutta gct
event in 2019 with 27 out of 36.
wow and there's already a huge and the
resume the draw in round one right so
that's already unavailable oh wow
but this move rook d8 why isn't this
move just
very very unpleasant
i don't know maybe he wants c6 king c7 i
the only thing i could have come i could
come up with is maybe c6 king c7
you're playing with a lot of fire there
i can play six now let's say c6 e6 and
it just looks extremely scary to my eyes
um probably explains why i'm not a
berlin player
weigh-in on this one christian isn't c6
hikari is completely lost right now
completely lost nicaragua is just
bluffing at this point totally yeah
everything he just got caught in some
sort of an opening trap but right now
he's completely lost and i really like
this move e6 if you take with the pawn i
go knight t5 i have so many threats
coming knight to g6 that's going to win
a piece you don't have the move knight
to c6 because this was the plan of uh
hikaru 97 knight c6 kicked the rook out
of the eighth round yeah now we take
take we go
95 this is such an everything is just
completely completely uh
and your extra disaster is a double pawn
so it doesn't really matter
yes if you play knight c6 knight takes
e6 c2 c4 just but then you never unpin
yeah this is just a full piece basically
right those two pieces never end
absolutely with the bishop on b2
stopping g5 bishop g7 yeah this just
looks lost frankly i think hikar also
knows he's he's busted something has
gone by the way rook to e8 not knight to
e5 rook to e8
probably still fine a bit playing for
bishop g7 a bit no i would never i want
more of course we do that
that would be cashing our chips really
yeah i'm very surprised by this i really
could see no reason not to play 95 at
all i just yeah this this kind of shocks
me so it doesn't spoil anything i assume
but why not 95 exactly knight c6
maybe on a very very good day playing
for some kind of counter play on the
yeah we could have stopped black from
making any moves in this game precisely
for some reason we chose not to but
yeah
this is still horrible
by the way is time a factor at all peter
shouldn't be uh levon is on three and a
half uh five uh hikaru is down to a
minute but i think that's sort of the
least of his problems yeah yeah it's the
position
he's gone 96 and yeah this is my this is
my issue with rookie 8.
if you allow bishop d6 you're still
going to be winning or or what he's done
now yeah rookie 697 you can take on g7
now you're winning but this is a game
black will have a bishop uh you know the
rook will actually get to g8 maybe but
how do you get your pieces out if i go
knight just 95. maybe we never take on
d7 or g7 anyway yeah i think so yeah oh
i really really don't like this i mean
he's still a huge favorite to win this
game king of one king hits you just to
stop rook g81 and then yeah yeah he
knows he knows what he's doing but
uh
i think he sold carl i think he sold his
position so short here yeah yeah he
really really uh cashed his ship said
oh boy uh this is how we don't win such
positions yes this is
us
a4
i think king c6 c4 rook a8 yeah but
thinks oh b-a and then rook c4 i get a
rookie four yeah oh ruka feta4 yeah that
was clever this is yeah
i don't know this is honestly honestly
staggering for me that lavon chose this
path b takes a4
i don't like that decision
you know although still i mean i'm very
very shocked by by all of these
developments because yeah we
[Music]
a5 b5
knight d2 yeah i mean he's still he's
still in control but he'll play bishop
d4 and then rook a8 i guess yeah bishop
d4 will go somewhere he'll play rook 8
or takes a four
you you legitimately don't win these
positions now and uh i'm not even sure
how winning we are how about rook f3
okay eight yes i understand h4 and then
a3 or something but the bishop on d4 is
very strong we're only one pawn up now i
think
it wants you recapture on a4 this is
extremely extremely mystifying to me
lavon
generally understands these things
as well as anybody in in the chess world
really absolutely so
so again rook f3 rook a8 something to be
said for c3 i agree with you
wholeheartedly the bishop on d4 such a
strong bishop i want to get rid of it
and this is very very confusing to me
agreed
completely agreed uh one thing i could
also offer rook f3 rook a8 there's some
time i can go
rook h3
yeah but it becomes a race and exactly
what i wanted
in all of those races the bishop on d4
is just such a such an incredible
advantage over the knight on g2 because
it controls it controls all of our
queening squares and
indeed i really well that's right
that caught us but then there's okay two
in the end
i mean
are you actually ever worried that you
could be even losing this position yes
so c3 rook takes a two okay
this should never have been
this this game like there is no way this
should have been what this game is
exactly right
you can tell we
you can take invoking c6 we're in we're
in the in the square i don't know like
you have to calculate maybe it's okay
because i go f6 is no i don't think i i
don't think we won that
not at all look five is not the way we
play
by the way and now f4 g5 i mean white is
still ahead
clear uh in terms of tempe like under
normal circumstances you never lose and
you maybe even win sometimes
i'm not a fan of rook five i thought he
was going to go king season i'm very
surprised yeah i'm very surprised he
didn't just go king 16 c5 before b3 that
was the whole point yeah
uh hikaru missed an opportunity
has won
his game against sam shankland oh again
sam's picking up where he left off
yesterday
ooh that was horrible harsh
harsh
you're being unnecessarily harsh on sam
i think yeah roxy won check i think we
go to eat uh he doesn't even want to
allow rook rook g2 so he will but i mean
he will have to uh he will have to allow
the rook to get behind the pawn so i
guess he would go king e3 and if you
want to play rook h2 yeah we go f5 f6 we
give up one but it gets to f7 this looks
like it might be by the way a big result
fabiano uh defeated mvl in the uh direct
encounter yeah this looks more and more
like
five we are watching uh we will be
watching alternatively the two people
who are
in the race here
yeah
yeah the the f-pawn is more dangerous
for sure
rook c1 very expecting
ah he wants rookie one check this is
very clever if you have six you will
play rookie one check first f4
yeah check uh king of four king of four
and king e5 but then the b pawn will
start running but my guess is the the
white pawns are faster but
it's now kind of yeah and now we go b4
right before b3
but also before i can go up to f41 f5
yeah
is very very safe yeah in terms of like
stopping 2900
is a good move i would take on c5 yeah
yeah no it's a good endgame that's a
good engine for sure uh
20 seconds he might actually go for it
because b3 c4 c3 b2 is happening
very very very very fast happening
rather quickly so
yeah yeah he does go for it yeah and uh
now they will both get quince and levon
will play queen takes c5 and now he is
very very safe from losing
i don't yeah you can't take on h6
because it loses the queen in one move
yeah there's
objectively this is probably just a draw
because black is the first one to give a
check
uh so h4 appears to be
queen takes h4 i think the players will
shake hands at that point
almost yeah if you can manage to play
king g6 with the pawn yeah yeah like
something like this
not allow queen g5 play queen of four
kings
oh yeah
it's gonna it's gonna be difficult to
create like after that h6 is still not
hanging so i think for kikara just go
king a8 here and say you know this is a
stable
i don't actually need to you know move
anything or king a6 exactly like
clock times yeah queen a5 queen f4 check
he goes yeah and yeah but the problem is
yeah we've we've got an ah we have five
minutes queen five queen h5 is a threat
now
anticipation of that yeah yeah he
actually wins the
he actually wins the h6 pawn and now you
have to defend this this is not going to
be so much fun to defend queen takes h6
i guess
you can definitely lose the check check
in fact
the king is actually he hikaru went back
from b3 to b7 it should have been on b3
in terms of uh
uh
like what we know about these queen
endings uh the black the black king
needs to be around like a two b one
square
the pieces are
wonderfully wonderfully probably just
winning for white now yeah you have to
assume you can't give any checks
because uh there will be an
interposition yeah so queen h6 currently
stops g7 i thought you're supposed to go
towards uh not towards the center but
where is the fifth and fourth ranks
well i mean ideal square is up like b1a2
and he was there and then he went away
from there
he was already he was already there at
one point between c5 check queen
you're still not there yet
no no you i mean on 10 seconds you're
like you're not absolutely guaranteed to
win this at all
like this is a confusing endgame i don't
know why we moved to this yeah i think
yeah this is what they 24 check and then
you start coming out with the king
i think we discussed this with piraleco
in a recent uh when we were covering
covering the olympiad
uh the trick there apparently when when
you start looking at how it the engine
converts this yeah you protect the pawn
with the queen with the queen and then
it becomes much much easier for you i
think this is it yeah i think this is it
because
there's another
he doesn't see the check but yeah now
queen c5 or queen d4 and you will give a
check from like d3 or somewhere and it
will be over
going before check and yeah a3 b3 or c4
and then g8 queen yeah this is yes
nicely done
and now that the
motion square you can play g8 there's
never a stalemate you can always do this
it seems like there's not going to be a
2900 not just
he's winning but uh he's not winning as
quickly as i expected at one point it
looked like it would it will not be a
very
long game but
he should still win f6 of seven yeah
like you the moment the pawn reaches of
six you you become a lot kind of more
yeah sung blind about the whole thing
yeah yeah rook b8 now yeah we're there
are we there yet yes we are
yes we are and just in time for the
handshake
wow very
only one win
in round ten
but if i'm reading it right i'm seeing
five wins in round 11.
that was uh quite remarkable young wow
shakira by the way once again played
that really really long king queen's
gambit accepted that he played against
uh
they continue uh it's actually against
them between them again yes yes yes it's
the same is the same opening i'm not
even sure exactly who uh changed things
up
played h5 yes yes yes which is actually
a bad move but i guess from a blitz
perspective it's not such a
terrible decision bishop to g4 bishop
takes f7 and of course king to e7 is a
huge mistake if you do go king to d7
that basically just wins a piece you
cannot go queen to h4 because after h6
without the king on e7 and without any
discovery checks you're just simply
losing you can resign at this point i'm
going to take on g5 next so the best
move after king to d7 seems to be bishop
to e6 but this is just a piece right a
piece up you don't have as many uh
forces around my king i still have to
like be very careful about my king after
the move f4 but still it should be black
who is favored to potentially strike in
this game unfortunately for him he did
not see that he played the move king to
e7 and after queen to h4 i have to say
this is just a very comfortable end game
for white which uh mamedyarov went on to
win now this was another big game the
one between mvl and caruana and it was a
very balanced uh fight up until all the
way until the end check this out
after the move knight to c4 all you have
to do is find a way to approach
the uh the pawn on d4 with your king and
the best way to do that is to go f4
followed by king to f2 king to e2 and
king to d3 you cannot play the move king
to f1 because that runs into knight to
d2 without a lot of time on his clock he
played the move bishop to d3 but now
you're just simply not in time i'm going
to go knight to b2 which he did of
course i'm not going to take on uh a3
and allow my knight to be trapped but
then i'm just simply going to go d3 d2
d1 there's no way to stop black is going
to be a piece up black is going to go on
and win and actually after knight to b2
nvl resign and the big game was this one
ferugia versus jeffrey let's see what
happened in this one once again first
opened with the english
c4 c5 g3 and he got a very pleasant
advantage this early on uh attack on the
king side with the move h4 i really like
this plan just to kind of give something
to think about for a black h5 is going
to come and your opposition is going to
get weakened around the king excuse me
peter
no sorry
we'll keep going uh d6 queen to d2
bishop to d7 b3 queen to e7 bishop to b2
a6 e3 rook to b8 and this was the
critical moment because finally white
gets uh to a break in the center with
the move d4 and i'm going to be in time
to go castle get my king off uh the e
file do not allow any sort of e takes d5
and opening up of the queen and that's
actually going to spell big trouble for
black b5 castle not d5 as i was
mentioning because this just loses after
e takes d5 of course that's a check
castle first you take on c4 but i don't
have to take back
i can take advantage of the fact that
your king is in the center and i can
play d5 which was found by ali reza
giving him a tremendous advantage in the
center and the king never got better in
the position as you can see queen takes
the six queen takes p3 this is the
exchange that he won all the way at move
22. it did take all the way until move
93 to finish the game but he did so and
right now he has a four point lead if
i'm not
and here are current standings peter a
three-way tie for second uh with the
first place honestly kind of it looks
like with a four-point lead and both of
his direct pursuers losing in this round
hikaru plays him next round yeah this
really starts looking like maybe last
chance saloon for the entire field
exactly or it will become just a race
for second right as and nepo joins the
big way tie for first time for second i
apologize and uh as we get ready for
break uh we asked the players what
attributes are necessary to be a good
blitz player as well as a good rapid
player these are their answers
[Music]
what are the three most important
attributes that make for a good rapid
and blitz player
three attributes okay i mean i think
there's one certainly that stands above
the head and shoulders above the rest
which is certainly intuition the ability
to kind of intuitively sense a move
versus doing pure calculations and what
that means is just in a couple of
seconds you can sort of sense what the
options are you just pick one based on
intuition as opposed to having to do
calculations
that's the first one i think second one
is probably just general time management
again sort of it comes back to intuition
but sensing what moments to use the 15
20 seconds versus making a move
instantly
that's the second one and if there's a
third one i mean i don't know maybe it's
just confidence i can't really think of
a third one specifically it makes a huge
difference
i think number one would be
probably the instincts the gut feeling
second would be the calculation
and the third would be resilience
a good tactical vision
good openings and
obviously good time management because
you need to always
i mean ideally you should always be a
head on the clock if you want to do well
in this tournament for me i would
probably put intuition as as the first
i think
if you can feel good moves you're going
to do really well just because
yeah you really don't have much time to
sort of work everything out i feel like
the ability to
keep your nerves would be
a close second for me
finally
maybe just
the experience factor i would say like
in general if if you have more
games under your belt especially rapid
and blitz
you'll you'll know you'll sort of know
what works well if i knew maybe i would
be a better rapper and blitz player
myself i've really brought my classical
chess up to be the absolute being the
world elite and one of the best players
in the world and rapping and blitz i'm
good but it's been lagging behind so
i've been trying to get better and
hopefully this term will an opportunity
to uh to improve further um in general i
think it's it's very good instincts very
quick tactical vision uh for example if
you see a tactic in two seconds and i
see it in three in classical this just
doesn't matter at all but in blitz it's
a huge advantage so just having a very
quick board vision and uh and having
extremely good intuition and i think
also having a more narrow opening
repertoire and knowing it deeper helps a
lot more uh making sure that you can
remember your stuff is is very important
because you can't think oh uh i checked
this a year ago what was the move and
spent four minutes thinking about it it
doesn't work and wrapped in blood it's
the way it does in classical of course
to play
fast
not mistakes
last one is big luck
and
just to not miss
big blunders
calculations and instincts like this
ability to
to play fast to to have a good flow
especially in blitz
the ability to you know
muddy waters to
complicate the game to play
which in classical will not matter so
much but you know epidemics it's
this opportunity like to be so resilient
that your opponent can
let you sleep sleep away because uh with
one and uh another you know tough move
of defense
at the end it can be frustrating
especially if you as your parents so
that's also very important
and of course keeping composure like um
you know because every
especially in blitz you get down to your
last few seconds almost every game so
there you really need like to be focused
on the game and nothing else to keep
your naps
yeah you have to be very sharp at all
the time so it's
it's
sometimes you are in a
very good shape but
physically but your mind just doesn't
work that day so it's it's you have to
be a little bit lucky so everything be
together
so but yeah it's a very interesting
format and not too many people are very
good at this format so it's an
interesting way to follow a chess well i
think that chest strength generally
translate across all formats so you
won't see a robin blitz player who's bad
at classical chess or vice versa you
can't really search for perfection and
rapture with some controls especially in
blitz you have to rely more on your
feeling and
throw caution to wins to the winds a bit
more if you try to you know control
everything and make sure everything's
perfect then you run the risk
and the likelihood that you'll run into
severe time trouble and even if you
played a perfect game and you're totally
winning just one blunder is enough to to
ruin a flawless game and to lose game
uh i think you know it's like
i think it started covering who said
like there are like
three you know
three most important things which which
is just player
should have to be successful it's luck
luck and luck
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to rounds upcoming round 12
of our blitz tournament and these are
your standings in what appears to really
uh
a very very interesting developing fight
per second yes indeed that's exactly how
it looks three-way tie per second there
leave all half a point behind yeah juan
alireza is running away with it and uh
before we get too far deep uh
we made a mistake we overlooked our cue
boutique how could we
unforgiveable unforgivable what is is
today we are uh offering uh gcc men's
jacket a lightweight cotton zip up gray
jacket with pockets all with with
pockets so this is one good thing that
they keeping your hands yeah the club
the club always knows
what they're doing on that front
features the gct logo on the front left
and as with everything else
available online at cubaticstl.com
fantastic and as we get ready for round
12 do the honors peter yeah which game
are we gonna watch oh yeah who knows
there's five of them yeah you're right i
pick one i mean i'll go with number one
how about hikara versus farouza that
will yeah as you say it's the last
chance saloon
does feel like it yeah i mean i think
there's there's also actually young has
already played against ires in in round
one of today and uh mvl is not really
having such a great start to the day so
far so it really does feel that
hikaru needs to win a particularly
upsetting game against study resources
really demolish not only does the lead
needs to be cut down to three points
post haste but also alireza needs to
stop playing well for some reason
exactly
yeah but he has been playing uh
fantastic throughout christian in fact
uh it's amazing how consistent uh ali
reza has been absolutely and i remember
him in 2021 in paris actually he had an
amazing
rapid as well or i think it was the
blitz perhaps but nevertheless he did
not have two sections in which he was so
consistent right now this is what we're
seeing from the young man and he could
potentially just clinch the title right
now
what are you expecting for this map for
this game something of beat i don't know
what hikara will play but i'd like i'm
i'm expecting some sort of knight f3 b3
uh
type stuff because i don't think hikaru
wants to compete with uh in in terms of
uh
theoretical knowledge yeah well he
played this c4a3 as well but also ali
reza played c483 but they they both have
been very you know heavily dipping into
that well uh from the white side so
probably not the best
option from uh
from hikaria knight of c3b3 was always
you know very high on the list there
perhaps not followed by g3 we have seen
at least one game in this tournament
where it was followed up by a very very
quick g3
well they actually played this line in
the rapid portion and alireza outplayed
him with black pieces he won a very
important game
yeah castles castles uh
and then g4 is the main move other moves
exist but d4 is by far the the the main
move and after she takes d4 knight takes
d4 bishop c7 i'm expecting bishop c7 yes
there we go yeah there we go and uh
this is currently sort of i think well
understood to be nothing at all for for
white now knight takes d4 queen d6 yeah
this is supposedly extremely comfortable
for black
i i had occasion to look at this because
i
there was a moment where i was
kind of activity playing this line with
white
and the discovery of them of bishop c7
made me stop pretty much
i remember that i kind of gave up on the
whole idea by
the whole point is that the desirable
knight f3 bishop g4 renews the threat
and unless you're willing to part with
your pawn you're probably gonna have to
play g3 yeah you you end up having to
play g3 and uh those types of positions
yeah g3 bishop a5 was a very recent game
at the olympia i'm struggling right now
to remember exactly who against yeah
there we go the point of bishop five is
to kind of uh you're expecting the rook
to land on iban after we play bishop h3
yep uh so that's a nice little pin yeah
all of this is still following that game
at the olympia and now you can simply
take on the two play knight e4 queen g6
why can't i there it should be but for
some reason it's not on my screen
popping up the game no
it's it's definitely something uh we
covered during the olympiad very very
recently and uh
yeah this is a comfortable position for
black because of how strong the bishop
h3 is
yes
it's thanks to uh having provoked the
move g2 g3 of course a lot of
light square weaknesses uh ikaru is one
of those players well not
not unexpectedly who really really loves
his two bishops so i guess he's very
aware of the fact that black has
equalized but equally so he's thinking
that well
oh no queen g6 no knight g5 none of
those stuff super 5 is a it feels like
maybe a bit of no maybe it's not
no i want to say it's a drawer because
f3 clearly he's preparing to meet the
three with knight takes g3 but there is
rook c6 h6 made there i thought careful
yeah
i thought he was trying to make a draw
but maybe not alert alert uh b4 by the
way just stop queen takes a3 ideas we
definitely want to challenge
the c file with rook c1 queen g6 game
very quickly and now we want knight g5
next movie all night takes you through
the currently tonight e3 is a big threat
but honestly in terms of like achieving
a large advantage i would claim that
maybe knight g5 is an even bigger threat
because as things stand right now if you
allow knight g5 you'll probably have to
trade on a 5.
and you're in your structure on the king
side with the knight on g5 and the queen
already on f5 will look miserable true
really really miserable so yeah this
this looks like this may have uh uh
somewhat back for backfired as an
opening choice for hikaru because he's
playing quickly he clearly knows uh
knows what is impressive yeah yeah and
uh
yeah i'm picking i'm thinking black here
any day so i guess i have to you you
have to go to d1 either one of the roofs
to try well it would be one d3 nine g5
f3 no you can't even play f3 how do you
react to knight g5 though so rook ed1
knight g5 maybe like h4 or something
along those lines
i think played
right
uh yeah knight g5 h4
and then i hope i don't get checkmated
basically which idea we can start with
h5 but i still like my g5 i don't think
we need to postpone it h4 i have a
number of options there
the question i would ask white well done
you played rook on e1 to d1
what's your next choice after h5 no
christian was suggesting h4 here h4 yeah
which i think like if nothing else we
can just go to bishop d3 and knight of
three check against whatever capture you
you prefer right yeah why is fighting
for equality here i'm i'm fairly certain
why this is why
i'm not sure white is winning this fight
no he's not bishops of opposite color
it's all about who has uh the initiative
against the opponent's king knight f3
check looks very compelling queen takes
f3
bishop takes d3 yes you can take the
pawn but bishop e4 i would like you
suffering yeah i would argue that maybe
actually playing h4 here and just giving
up that exchange whichever move order
you prefer
whether you start with another three
check or whether you start with bishop
the ecz3 i want to take one f3 take on
d3 give you that exchange take on d5 and
claim that maybe my bishop on d4 will
provide enough cover to not lose the
results look at that time difference
right now and then falling under two
minutes alireza still four minutes 28
seconds you know
forgetting about any kind of result here
but just the time difference is so
unusual to see ikaru the one
three minutes behind on the clock and by
the way in the battle of the second
position it seems like mvl is slowing
down a little bit dominguez definitely
with a dominant position and carol goes
f4 uh i mean everything we said earlier
still sort of applies but i guess having
the f2 square for the king is quite
useful i think i'm going knight f3 check
first probably because i i would like to
avoid bishop d3 queen d3
so i go another three check first you
will have a kind of an unfortunate
choice between allowing me to take on d4
and then it's a symmetrical structure
but white played after f4 for no reason
right so white is going to be worse
forever well you can take on f3 i will
play bishop takes d3 i will bring the
bishop back to e4 and also very very
little fun yeah so let's try to somehow
liquidate everything knight f3 i take
yeah take on the triangle rook c1 and i
try to defend that yeah i think this is
what you're supposed to do but so yeah
bishop b4 followed by like i don't know
d6 f6 h5 we just play slowly
yeah very very comfortable advantage for
the rest of the game i'm not saying
winning but
we all know we all know who's better
yeah we all know it's only black we can
play for victory there it's quite clear
you can also just take on d3 and put the
knight back on e4 that's also not
horrible but at some point maybe we have
to start talking about the fact that a7
is hanging so it's slightly sharper
and i mean no sharper but double edged
it maybe gives white a semblance of a
hope somewhere i i would argue uh bishop
takes d3
rook takes d3 or queen takes d3 knight
e4 take on a7 h5
yeah there's also b6 i mean maybe we can
never take on a7 because the queen on g6
provides cover yeah the take stakes
happened apparently
knight h3 might be made like looking at
the bar
looking at the bar this appears to be i
mean rook c2 yeah knight f3 or yeah
another three followed by roxy
appears to be winning right
and yeah he he sees those things he just
sees those things yeah i can confirm to
you that's right now you have three yeah
completely he's just killing f2 roxy too
yeah king
91 check is kind of strong right now
it's even stronger than even stronger
than ruxin though
even stronger 91 quintex d3 you can
basically play 91 is a is a queen for a
piece right now yeah okay and that
the saint is rapid and blitz
no he hasn't seen it i mean he sees rook
c2 so he does that yeah yeah but like he
can go knight agent
like visibly upset because he was
preparing to resign and now like he is
you know in this kind of a foul mood of
why am i losing to a person who doesn't
see 91 check by the way you could also
play knight h4 check i think he wants to
play with two points
or rook c8 i like rook c8 the most
actually just get get full control over
the one open file you're ready to go
queenie for check and rook c2
this is horrifying
and hikaru knows it that h5 is just
completely lost yeah
queen check roxy 2 queen g2 check
is coming no this is terrible um
i'm ready to call this game this is i'm
still i'm still very shocked that there
is on four minutes did not find maybe
not four minutes
91 check did not seem like a difficult
but i mean he saw rooksytch the issue
was he he saw a clearly winning move so
he wasn't looking any further but
um
we haven't seen him miss very many
yeah that was uh kind of a glaring
tactical
opportunity there so you think that
hikaru played king of king g2 instead of
king f2 just because he wanted to resign
no no
but i'm pretty i'm pretty sure i like i
was watching him quite closely i'm
pretty sure he saw knight one check
and
as roxy too was coming in he started
shaking his hand ahead and i think that
was basically
why aren't you pushing me out of my
misery right
uh queen takes h2 immediately roxy won i
guess rook c4 we don't really want to
give up control over the one open file i
think rook c4 is the uh the champion
yeah just to
not have to worry about the white rook
activating even though take stakes and
h5 or take stakes and f6 probably also
reasonably comfortably winning but
exactly no yeah i'd play rook c4 okay
rook c4 i take on a7 yeah we go i don't
know h5 or
whatever you like yeah
it's still horrible yeah rook c4 i'm not
trying to make the case
black is not winning yeah rook c2 yeah
we take we take an a7 yeah we take on a7
and we hope nothing falls but
something will fall something's good
he's reaching for what else is he
supposed to do yeah i mean if you don't
take on a7 you really don't have very
much going for you here i i guess uh
queen c3 yeah let's see rook d1 at least
quincy three quid ah you have rook takes
d5 there in the end yeah true is fair
that is true
i like your f6 h5 g5 ideas just kind of
structurally yeah we've taken control
over the c file there is no count to
play we can just play f6 king of seven
h5 g5 go after the white something just
be said for b5 too just to also
get way too much in this game more than
he deserves he's also somehow now ahead
on the clock yeah 30 seconds for ali
reza you know this is a
i would play b5 here just
freeze the queen side make sure that a5
a4 part b a4 b5 b6 might be quite good
for white just in case we ever get a
chance to put the rook on c7 i would
like my pawn to already be on b7 on v6
uh
hikaru goes for something slightly more
solid with rookie two and king f2 if
there was still upon h2 i would argue
this is maybe holdable by this point or
at least yeah there we go there we go i
like that i think maybe we have to play
for here
yeah a four b5 b6 rook b2 just go for it
well the problem is a4 ba b5 b5 a3 b6
queen b queen
mvl has won against lanier too much pain
in this one event for linear yeah this
is very really very unfortunate really
struggling yeah uh and some very very
sharp positions on other boards but this
is the one of course that we're watching
because it's really the most relevant in
terms of the
the tournament outcomes yeah it's
shocking that this is a game honestly it
should have been and it's still going on
yeah queen f3 was on
uh farouza's agenda there but now the
king
but he'll kill h5 king g4 exactly the
king is coming yeah
he's still of course winning but of
course this is this is way way too much
of a game considering what the position
was a bit early bishop c5 trying to put
the the rook on d4 yeah king h2 now
uh jeffrey and sam shanklin drew uh
yanipon she's a bit better against uh
but probably not a winnable position so
why is he not pushing the h-bomb that is
i don't know questions i don't know but
he will yeah he will and eventually you
have to like you have to play
yeah queen takes
and then we start pushing the g pawn
yeah like uh
yeah this is no this is actually not the
reason i do have rook to f4 right yeah
this is not that easy to win i think
yeah we go after the a3 pawn now yeah we
we create a different destruction
and you can't really like if you target
yeah you you can't really drive whoa
whoa whoa
what was he taking
three king g4 he didn't like king g4
and okay and now he can sort of uh
reestablish that thing yeah i guess king
g3
go for queen g1 champion
okay now we go queen
bishop f6 issue maybe
h4 yeah
would be a mistake bishop c5
the ball ending i think is winning for
black like the the thing here is i think
i think we can go queen g3 queen takes
c3 yeah
but no okay bishop p7 doesn't work
because if queen takes c3
now he'll go back to g3 and he'll go
back to g3 we can take on a3 and take on
e3 yet now we are very very happy i
think this venue was winning even
without the queen takes it right but it
did it was very nice yeah it definitely
is winning now for sure the extra extra
extra so we've made we've made a very
clear improvement here as black by
winning an additional queen of one yeah
you can't take on d5 he'll lose the rook
uh he'll probably get it done but he
will be kind of pushed which
what's remarkable for me is in a
completely completely losing position
carter's shaking his head as if i should
be saving this but i don't know why i'm
not
able to save this yeah a kind of a
feeling like this yeah which i don't
think is entirely justified this is this
is the end yeah you just get mated now
queenie one is a threat and you can't
stop it
and uh yeah hikaru
farouza he knows putting a signature he
knows on an amazing amazing tournament
our congratulations to forever for a
very very big victory and we do have a
draw the very end in this game between
levon and fabi bishops of opposite color
yeah
not as
bloody not as bloody around as we've had
previously there's a bunch of
of seemingly very interesting but still
draws but alireza wins and mvl wins
which means that uh i think we really
have the first and second yeah i really
we have to switch to watching the fights
for a second by this point because yeah
that game
we held our breath for 2 900.
uh blinked twice and uh there went 20
rating points for uh and this is the you
know
the curse of being as high rated as
these guys are you know one you know one
unfortunate game costs you so much that
uh magnus is sitting there tell tell me
about it
and
let's take a look at the gct graphic of
uh the points that are available uh
christian this is where you uh started
the show
absolutely yes what i wanted to say is
that
we we've all kind of made peace with the
fact that wesley will get overtaken
clearly i get the feeling wesley will be
fourth not even third because that is
ali
could be one yeah
probably no no nbl and i think libon as
well because the one is kind of surging
in this tournament he's i think he only
needs four points and four points is
seventh place i think he's currently
like in fourth yeah or they're about yes
so i think it's very likely that the the
singfield cup will start with probably
mbl in the lead i would assume and then
probably alireza followed by livon right
and then wesley on 22 and a half and how
far behind will fabby be if you give
fabby i don't know
fifth place
he'll still be behind wesley he'll be
playing
yeah i'm gonna have to get fabi's gonna
have to fight for third actually i'm
guessing yeah but uh the results of the
round peter yeah let's take a look uh
after after the round there is a four
point lead but only uh only one person
is within this sort of quote-unquote
touching distance of four points with uh
uh six rounds to go uh mvl is now in
clear second uh janine palmishi who drew
his game in clear third levon and hikaru
tied for fourth and shakhriar and
jeffrey are tied for fifth sixth story
for me it's so very rare to have seen
such a pure blitz game as we just saw
between ali rays it seemed to me that
ali reza
got an edge out of the opening those
light squares converted it into a
material advantage and never let it go
that was a pretty impressive it was
really yeah apart from that one strange
bleep of here no i'm not
finding 91 check which would have just
prompted an immediate resignation right
but he actually at times it seemed like
he might actually allow hikaru back into
the game but no no no things were kept
under control
and kristen uh you
what caught your eye in that uh
round we just saw mesmerized by the game
the misery for dominguez unfortunately
uh deepens with this game as well i was
telling you in the middle of the round
that he was having a dominant position
against mvl and that almost would have
finished this tournament but mvl keeps
that touching distance and let's uh see
how that happened e4 he gets uh the car
con on the board of course both of these
players are very well versed in the kara
and a very aggressive way of playing
with this move g5 we also saw ali reza
essay these type of ideas against
dominguez in the rapid portion i do
believe it was the last round of day
three or day two in which ali reza won a
very very important game to maintain his
lead over the pack now let's see if
dominguez has improved and he did
because he immediately started with his
a4 a5 expansion taking more and more
space on the queen side nevertheless
black also stabilizes on the king side
g4 bishop to e4 f3 take on d4 and a very
interesting sequence right now taking on
e4 now at least you don't have to worry
about the light square bishop so the
king despite the fact that it it looks
quite naked it's actually quite uh
strong and a safe in the position for
white bishop takes e5 knight to b5 queen
to c5 king to h1 a6 this was a
tremendous tremendous blunder what he
should have done black that is would
have been to play h5 and try to create
something try to open up the h file and
put some pressure on this pawn on h2 he
did not do that he lost the beat with
the move a6 and after knight to c3 white
is starting to put a lot of pressure on
the structure knight ac4 is a big threat
you have to defend against that which he
did with the move queen to c6 this was
the critical position dominguez as we
will see in the next few moves had the
right idea but just not the right
execution right now he should have
played this move rook to a4 the point
behind it is that not that you want to
take on e4 because anytime you touch
that pawn potentially i will be able to
take advantage of this newly created pin
but what i want to do is play the move
rook to c4 and the queen in fact doesn't
have a lot of squares if you go to d6
after that i'm going to be able to take
with the knight and that's going to hit
the queen as well it doesn't feel like
you're going to be finding a very good
placement for your queen if you try to
play the move b5 i just simply take
knight takes b6 rook takes e6 you lose
that pawn and my king is actually quite
safe not only that you're losing the
pawn you don't have time to take back
the rook because of this move bishop to
b5 setting up this nice pin picking up
the queen and that's all she wrote so
after rook to a4 it's very very
difficult to find a move for black to
defend this pawn on e4 if you try to do
that with the move knight to c5 i just
simply pin up the knight once again
you're going to have so many problems to
deal with big move rook to a4 and of
course the critical move which i do
believe was the one that dominguez was
worried about was the move e3 and that's
a discovery check the problem is after
bishop to f3 you will lose that pawn on
e3 you have to draw back with the queen
pick up the pawn on e3 my king is safe i
have a tremendous initiative going on
towards your queen side as white and
this just spells trouble for black so
big big moment he did not do that played
move knight to g2
rook to d8 queen to e1 and that just
allowed black to get his own play going
castle f5 now my pawn structure
with the spear on e4 is just quite safe
and putting a lot of pressure on your
king side a very dominant display after
that by mvl allowed him to win and keep
touch with ali reza on four points
behind still quite massive lead for the
young frenchman thank you christian a
nice missed opportunity there for
linear in this upcoming round 13 we've
got two favorites yeah we always want
our audience to break the favorites for
us but let's take a look at our pairings
coming up
round
13
we'll come up in a moment we can tell
yeah and uh this is something uh
something of a teaser of events coming
up later this week sinkhole cup will
restart with the opening ceremony i
believe tomorrow and the first round on
friday right
and this is a tournament which will see
the return of magnus carlsen yes indeed
and on thursday we will have all of
those
nice
photo opportunities book signings and
what have you but magnus harrison uh
returns on tour to steal a lot of
grandchild store points and this is the
blitz uh for round 13. we've got two
great matches that we've really
particularly interested in here we have
to kind of start making an executive
decision watching
has has been an incredibly impressive
cruise but it also does feel like the
the race for first has been run right
right point with um
mvl
will be a huge fight for second place
exactly i think this is the one we
should be watching because there's a yes
he's running away with it yes we know
how it ends perhaps it's time to start
watching some
we should start seeing other people yeah
fair enough we'll go with the mvl game
for a marquee matchup but yes we will
keep an eye on the farouza and that game
that mvl just
saved if you will
you you feel that's like a two-point
swing because when you see rook a4
it is so bad it is it is bad but uh
these types of incredibly messy carols
where you know the material balance gets
disrupted extremely early on like black
didn't blunder sacrifice the beast by
move 12 or thereabouts in that game
even rook a4 doesn't really guarantee
you a win there with white but yes it
was a huge missed opportunity by lanier
but
sadly as someone who you know i've
played for the same club within a year
i've known him for ages and ages i
really like him yes it's painful to
watch him struggle as much as he's
struggling here he is a tremendous blitz
player i nobody really you know only he
might may know
what's what's happening but yeah he is
just not himself here and people are
taking advantage no question about it uh
blood in the water you've got to go for
it uh for yan uh you've gotten a chance
over these last few days to hang out
with john a bit
uh
you know for somebody who's about to
play for a world championship match he
really hasn't found his fifth gear he's
played well at times but
like the game with ali raza was a
paradox i mean it was a strange game
yeah uh perhaps he uh did not feel you
know successfully you know warmed up by
that point yeah
even though even though it was like
game 28 of this tournament you would
assume you've warmed up a little bit by
that right
but yeah he's he's been having a bit of
a strange tournament where he he
absolutely shows you know flashes of
brilliance he's absolutely capable of
but it does him does feel like he's
[Music]
uh i wouldn't say he's taking it easy
i talked to him and
he clearly still cares but uh
it's it's not the most intense
performance i've seen him produce right
for sure right exactly
and christian uh you uh
jump in for a moment
you know we know lanier we've watched
him over the years and you know it's
something like
you know when you're hot you know like
how do we replicate that
and when we're cold like ice cold
how do we get out of this uh it's very
difficult there's definitely something
psychologically uh going on right now
with lanier because generally he's such
a consistent player if i would have uh
to uh attribute the word to him it would
be consistency right he's been around 27
60 27 70 for a very very long time so
he's been playing with this type of
elite competition for a very long time
once again especially in this rapid and
blitz formats as well he is the world
bliss champion i do believe it was 2013
or 2014. so he has experience at this
level but right now he just simply
cannot uh play chess there's something
psychologically about his situation and
yeah it's very painful to watch i have
to say yeah you know
here are our uh predictions and uh hat
tip to you and alejandro the coaches of
the year
uh you know your players i felt it
coming i felt it coming i have to say
and for anastasia and i we're just
scratching our heads and wondering what
happened to hikaru in the rapid if he
just had a result there yeah he's a
defending champion yeah 50 in the rapid
would have made this an extremely
exciting two horse race right now right
very very exciting but he somehow uh
contrived to finish the rapid minus two
and of course a lot more chess after
this our final day of this event sing
phil cup the granddaddy of them all the
end of the grand chess tour coming up
then we have our ultimate moves the real
smackdown and uh
verbiage
verbiage is a very good word
and then the champions show down chess
9lx the bobby fischer fischer random
that will be coming up september 14th
through 16th all of these events
happening of course in st louis and then
we have our u.s open championship as
well as the women's championship in
october it has been quite a year where
we returned to over-the-board chess and
st louis has really been on the uh the
edge of the spear very nice to see you
and uh there there we see uh sam samsung
considering sitting down to play uh
the pineapple man and hikaru just looks
for lauren doesn't it
i mean you can only imagine what kind of
frustrations he's going through his head
yeah
he knew he was another dog to actually
win the event but he is now even
trailing in the fight for second exactly
this he probably did not expect
considering the the sizzling point he
was showing yesterday yeah
and i'm sure he wanted to touch that
2900 maybe yes for just one round but
still you can say look i made history i
am the first player that ever touched
2900 it's a live rating list
yeah and uh you know the these quirks of
math because
on a different day with a slightly
different you know constellation of
results that would have been enough that
that victory that brought him to 28 99.4
yes would have been
29.00 right and he wouldn't even need to
you know uh beat levon
right and then he would have played
maybe a different opening and the thing
you know
so much might have been rewritten yeah
an avalanche of things would have just
uh you know changed changed to
chorus there but so the things are
you know there
there was was a great swimmer from
australia thorpe
and there's a commercial of him entering
the sydney harbor
and he's swimming with whales and
dolphins and then he touches the golden
great gate bridge and he goes one
and starts swimming back towards
australia touching 2900 would have been
nice yes absolutely
okay as we get uh set for this uh
new round we're going to once again uh
be uh keeping our eye on nepo and mvl
yeah mvl at the board
uh
hardy handshake
now be before we've seen just kind of
the shirt that's the grand chest
the one on the left ah
well uh trying to figure out i'm gonna
have to refer to my top agent on this
one christian what is that shirt there
i'm trying to see it as well maybe even
wearing the french resistance yeah it
doesn't look like it no
no
maybe uh just unveil uh i think
earlier today was uh is that a motor
shop
maybe
maybe a bike shop
i don't know
i see some wings but i'm not 100 sure
what they signify
i was about to say does enviou have some
gel in his hair that needs a little
fixing uh i got a spare comb he had
anybody else
he had a good night's sleep
and we are off any no i didn't even get
a chance to ask about the king's gambit
oh come on
knight takes f7
no
definitely not the king's gambit a lot
of groans going on in the studio yeah
but at least it's saving us from me
starting to make movie references there
i was about to go on a movie reference
detour looking at that haircut
christian chuckling there in the
background
so again all
uh
dare i say it hundreds of kids yes maybe
a very very popular position yeah we're
still uh are still in very very familiar
territory knight g5 also not a novelty
but a reasonably rare move in this
position far rarer than let's say but
envel himself has played this uh a bunch
of times actually he played it against
fabian he played against wang hao
uh all some years back though all of
this is 2018.
the big question i was about to ask
of you was a is knight f7 a threat and
then uh
nepo said uh do your worse so there was
no threat queen f3
uh
94 94 looks extremely comfortable the
issue is yeah exactly this 94 will be
immediately met bishop takes h2 and then
clinton h4 check and then
uh yeah this is a kind of an interesting
interesting little idea because white
liquidates by force
into an end game where white is pointed
down but because black is so poorly
developed as of right now and the pawn
h6 is hanging you have to solve some
immediate issues uh dealing with that
because right bishop takes h6 is a
genuine threat huge question right now
so no question so let's go
yeah the most natural move is king so
then bishop play three and we've won the
f7 pawn right rook to e8
he wants to give up the pawn yeah
bishop h6 g6 uh and we're still actually
following uh some yeah and the el
querana still got here and actually mvl
van gaal also got to this position so
clearly both of them are very familiar
with what's going on wasn't it also
caruana wang ho or something along those
lines
um
uh no it's uh
so far at least on my screen it's all
mvl games but no no five games on the
white side why we did have this as black
and this is another one of those
positions where you can discuss whether
you prefer
the more solid structure or the bishop
bear
right i always tend to prefer the bishop
player but this doesn't look horrible to
me split pawns on f2 and h3
he like is one tempo away bishop d5 is
an interesting choice i was going to say
if blackburn
were in time to play b5 and then bishop
d5 right i would instantly feel that
black is at the very least not worse
right but bishop d5 here does allow
white to play c3 c4 right which is a
very important kind of an improvement
uh pushing the bishop away straightening
out our structure the trade of a pair of
rooks very beneficial because it just
does mean that once black plays the move
knight b6 uh one
white rook is going to will have to be
dedicated yeah yes dedicated to
protection of the chief opponent perfect
word dedicated to the
dedicated to the defense and to give you
an update hikaru is uh taking the bull
by the horns he's playing the pertz uh
the modern defense against shanklin and
his worst of course
as as you generally are really okay but
by design yeah by design um okay are you
uh yeah i was about to say are you
you're not breaking through on the
king's side look at the h4 h5 rugby one
i very much like i think with only one
rook left on the board i don't think
h4h5 achieves too much and ruby one has
a kind of a clever move because
if we promote b7 b6 we
no more b6 96 no longer is something we
need to worry about which i think is a
significant achievement and ib65
i wasn't sure it's so horrible for black
but you at least need to start
calculating and perhaps ian is
hoping that he will be able to just play
this
uh
comfortably comfortably and using common
sense instead of trying to calculate his
way out of potential trouble exactly uh
knight on d7
the ideal ideal square of course is f5
um
not letting their eva
not getting there easily uh sorry peter
and i very much like rookie one here
because again he's this is very clever
because we provoked v6 to stop knight b6
and now guys guys guys guys can we move
really quickly surely well that is a
very very striking position
versus levon
so levon touched the bishop from d7 that
was protecting the knight on c6 and
played the move bishop to f5 oh god
which allowed bishop takes c6
and that's just resignation oh this is
just so so unpleasant when this happens
to you yeah it's just yeah so this is
going to be like three pieces for for
actually i can take the rook on e8 if i
really want to uh queen a fork oh queen
b3 to touch the f7 pawn as well so e6 i
guess but i mean just bishop g2 and
knight takes f1 you resign
horrible
wow
he just left the c6 knight hanging yes
92 bishop five bishop takes c6
yeah this is
dope that was horrible five five days of
chess will occasionally do this to you
but true that still quite quite the
strike feels bad finger failure yeah
just gonna jump back to the mvl
apologies for that uh short detour there
but the knight is getting the f5 at
least the time you will probably it's
attempting to get there why either g6 or
g7 and you can't stop 97 you can try
stopping 96 but you can't stop knight g7
uh and the earlier point i was trying to
make about rookie one is that i think
black would very much like to play f6
king f7 in positions like this so rookie
one is aimed at sort of nailing that
bishop on a6 in place not allowing that
uh
improvement unravel
but uh jana is doing the right thing
here the pitch 26 is solid as you were
saying electron d7 needs to be improved
so he is improving it
and once it lands on the 5 it's very
difficult to imagine how black can be
much worse exactly you mentioned f6 and
king f7 would you do that now peter he's
played 96 so he did the answer is
since this game is probably going to
last for a while should we see the
resignation in the alireza game yeah we
could wait the vultures all
gathering around the table to see the
resignation i don't think that's going
to last yeah that's uh that game well
this is the
the live game i'll move to it okay why
not
so you probably have to go king to h8 if
you take one i don't quite understand
what talirez is doing i guess he is
simplifying into like he will be one
piece up at the end of this i would have
played bishop g2 i really don't know why
we're doing this like rook f7 knight g5
queen f6 the bishop on d3 still forks
two rooks
but i guess he just thinks that you know
the more pieces he gets off the board
the closer he is to the one thinking
yeah i don't want to continue
um still a bit surprising to me that he
chose
to you know in purely you know
mathematical terms i'm pretty sure this
is like the fifth best yes yeah still
completely winning though uh
true that uh but
five
you you you we're not seeing resignation
the resignation that we wanted to see in
the next 30 seconds yeah and the one
will actually play this end game now i
think because he has a pawn for a piece
and he also saved one against jeffrey a
very similar endgame this one yeah he
that was that was terrible jeffrey's
still shaking his head over that one
yeah i mean
if he actually saves this one i will be
no
no but no no you are sort of given given
you can't go
some leeway to continue which i think if
if the bishop just went back to g2 i
think leon would have been
very happily just moving on to the next
one exactly well very happy he's
probably not not the way to describe it
he would have moved on but he would have
moved on yeah anyway back to backstage
game i think because watching another
game with an extra piece is maybe not
that exciting for sure
to the mvl version sorry mvl gaming this
is the resume okay this is maybe
not interesting it didn't it
yeah okay uh the knight found a very
good blockading square peter
but why did manage to push d5 and
control some space yeah assume control
over the one open file on the board the
c file so
somehow again i just find this bishop on
f5 to be very annoyingly
placed in the way
i think the knight definitely belonged
there i don't know exactly if the bishop
belonged on b7
wherever it is it's
in the way
it's a bit in a way but it's difficult
to
you know move it and also it does sort
of an important job in particular now
that we've played the seven of six
three and defending e6 square suddenly
okay so the bishop goes back and king
goes to f7
this is the setup that you had liked
some time ago before i think we play
five i mean we don't have to but a5
bishop a2 and then maybe bishop c bishop
c2 sorry but a lot of rookie six is
very difficult fraught with danger yeah
i'm not sure how happy i am about this
entire construction i agreed um yeah
black seems comfortable but black also
is seems to be lacking moves to make
right which is
the setup we have on the board right now
seems very stable but how about bishop
c2 and knight f5 again that's the setup
i want bishop c2 rook team i think the
problem is i fight bishop c3 our biggest
issue is
if we move the knight away from d6 we'll
we kind of immediately get hit by bishop
b5 and that might be awkward i don't i
don't hate bishop c2 but he goes bishop
king g7 which is perhaps a nod in the
direction of preparing knight f7 yeah
yeah he wants to move the knight away
from d6 and he wants to do it in a way
that doesn't immediately lose to bishop
b5 and he wants to be able to play rook
takes dc5 and his king is uh when his
king's on f7 he's not touching the d5
pawn yeah
and also it's a not towards the fact
that white appears to maybe have gotten
the maximum like maybe g3 is live
bishop is here
in terms of things we can do here to
make our position better is maybe king
g3 king f4 maybe bishop a6 exactly yeah
maybe bishop a6 is a useful move
uh bishop c2 uh trying to provoke unveil
into playing a5 which removes further
things from the queen side also also
perhaps bishop b3 becomes a playable
idea ah so unveil goes for this now but
this is just very very safe king of fate
in fact maybe maybe you can claim black
is a little bit better but yeah should
be should just be a drawer okay seven we
take on a four i assume
and breaking news fabby has won and
jeffrey has won his game against
mamedyarov against shaq who did fabby be
by the way yeah dominguez ah
yeah that's true that's that's very sad
yeah that's just boy
yesterday was a was a disaster movie
featuring sam shankland and lanier
dominguez how is sam doing is sam
well somebody's playing against hikar
when hikaru is suddenly slowly
gaining control of that game i see from
that hurts and as you were saying black
slightly better yeah but it should be a
joy i already understand but
the petrov defense the russian defense
lives again uh this has not been a
refutation and ferugia has won his game
against aronia yeah finally not the
shocker that uh that either yeah
uh
is is it
yeah i was about to say uh kind of an
intimate i i was expecting bishop f7 and
bishop takes d5 and a draw shortly
agreed
it's
is uh nepo over playing his hand a
little bit there yeah i think i think he
suddenly finds himself in a position he
will have to defend
which yeah okay if you have to play a
4g4 you you can legitimately lose this
position now right
it's uh
it's still fine i would assume but
you've placed yourself under yeah okay
maybe not after this maybe this is yeah
this is a draw you know we take on d5 we
program b6 yeah but uh you you i mean
that eventual rook ending is just so
completely drawn that is true i have
just realized i won the piano g4 i'm so
proud of myself congratulations
yes
i think we can move to the hikaru game
yeah let's let's wait let's watch the
chicago game yeah
we're expecting a handshake and a draw
in that game and it was in fact and
somebody gave
maxine a comb
and we do have karu uh hikaru on the
offensive and he's getting ready to
check his uh opponent's king
clock time's a factor look so four
seconds four seconds
two
but i can just simply pick up the bishop
right now
rook b3 is even is is even more painful
and yeah queen a3 check and we will win
i assume some people sound like king c2
still surprisingly preserves the
immediate material but
yeah you you have to assume this is just
going to be winning by by hikari and
knight b6 is bringing more pieces into
we need to check and the the queen
yes
wow
yes so collapse at the end but he had no
time yeah no time when the position was
bad so
i think this was
a kind of a
model game uh in terms of playing a
dodgy opening just to put a position on
the board with pieces uh and no forced
variations and then continuing to make
moves until your opponent starts going
astray so hikaru wins but
that brings him somewhat in touch with
mvl i guess well that fight for the
second position between nepo mvl and
kara but christian
in that four rounds absolutely but just
to give you an example of how bad
linear's uh tournament is going on right
now
this one in this position with the white
pieces he played the move bishop to d3
allowed rook takes d2 and resigned on
the spot um it's a better position for
white slightly better sure i mean
they're black has some compensation on
the queen side c4 b4 you can do whatever
you want bishop to d3 is not the move
you want to make he just wants this
tournament to be over
right now and uh there's something in
the water because check what mamedyarov
did in this game so up to this point
everything was going just fine for him
a couple of uh inaccurate moves but it
doesn't matter that much after bishop to
g5 bishop to d6 you can just simply take
on f6 take on f6 and play a normal move
such as bishop to h6 preserve your
presence around the black king queen to
g3 to follow maybe f4 as well in the
position it definitely feels like white
has the initiative he played the move
queen to g3
just allowed f takes g5 oh pawn on g5 is
actually protected by the queen
everything is protected in the position
you just gave up uh one of your uh best
attacking pieces in the position in one
move for absolutely no compensation and
of course you can once again resign at
this point as white which he did later
on actually he just resigned after fdxg5
so a moment of blindness also
as well as dominguez some incredible
howlers in this round i think for people
in particular for people who aren't
really in running anymore
tiredness starts to kind of set in the
bones and uh yeah we're seeing some some
decision if you can call them decisions
we should errors that's not decisions
which you don't really see at this level
but yeah these are your standings uh
four four and a half points uh the lead
at the top mvl in clear second yanan
hikaru tied for third and we see alareza
is scoring ten and a half points in the
blitz to lead over hikaru nakamura is
nine and a half
there's no winning the blitz as well
yeah exactly uh four and a half point
lead but that fight for a second still
tight peter very much so and uh you we
shouldn't really be counting jeffrey out
yet i was about to say he's quietly
especially of people giving them pieces
yeah
in particular if you get gifts like this
maybe fabio right i mean that wasn't to
a degree he used to start winning games
but uh
yeah the the fight for second and and
third to the podium
is still very much a multi-multi-horse
race we're going to take a break and
we'll see on the other side see you then
[Music]
hey st louis the ascension charity
classic presented by emerson is back
this september don't miss the excitement
when the pga tour champions best compete
again all for charity september 9th
through the 11th at norwood hills
country club pro-am spots hospitality
packages vip tickets and more available
now at ascension charity
ascensioncharityclassic.com
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back and these are our standings
with five rounds to go uh already is
well losing i mean one more round he
probably will be mathematically
uncatchable exactly he leads by four and
a half with five to go but that fight
for a second peter sure it is warming up
yes mvl currently is in clear second but
two very very strong leads players are
hot on his heels with janja pomnischin
hicarona kamura being on 16 and a half
and jeffrey sean is on 16 points and
this uh leads us very nicely into our uh
bearings of the round because
jeffrey zhang is playing mbl i think
yeah i think we should start dedicating
our time to watching all of the people
fighting for second and third
but how convincing has feroza farouza's
results been how many raiding points has
he uh he's picked up
he's he's up 74.6 blitz points
and is up to a very very clear second uh
behind hikaru kamuri in the world uh
world rankings uh in the blitz section
uh
2869 a very nice rating all of those
pairings as you can see are very
attractive but once again jeffrey young
versus mbl that's going to be our
marquee matchup we'll keep the fabi and
parousia game as plan b
and what
what a successes has been for jeffrey a
wild card player
and he's in here with a shout uh
fighting for second christian coming in
as a wildcard but he actually got the
call to compete in this event with less
than a week right so he didn't have a
lot of power to prepare he had to just
book his tickets count st louis and
compete against the best chess players
on the planet and this is exactly what
he's doing so successfully right now i
have to say i'm quite impressed with
this young man in the days of michael
jordan we would say it's about the shoes
it's all about the shoes they definitely
fit jeffrey is sporting
those nice shoes by the way
the red shoes
yeah nice
uh give them a little lift off here uh
what is jeffrey going to have to do he's
a point behind against mvl
obviously a win would be ideal but uh
where could he upset mvl the most
perhaps
i think he has been playing 1d4 against
greenfield players he he beat me like a
drama in the previous edition of this
event last year by uh
finding a kind of a [ __ ] in the armor
of
of
my greenfield knowledge there if you're
going for a very very topical line i did
not expect and ah
so did there we go
or did you just forget it i he he
actually this will this will have to be
corrected and this is absolutely mayor
culpa he he found a sport in my course
where
uh the the evaluation doesn't change but
i actually missed the move entirely in a
very critical position i like i covered
seven moves and there's move number
eight there which
was not covered and i tried figuring out
over the board how super i'm supposed to
react pick something and what i think
just loses by four so like by move 20
after 16 being heavy theory but move 20
i could resign so whenever you play the
chrome field are you worried that all
that all your your opponents know
precisely your preparation due to your
not precisely though because i do or you
leave some things uh i i do have backup
options like i i stand by every single
every single thing i say in the course
like the there's no lying but there's
definitely
you know some things kept uh as kind of
second options
in at least in some spots by the way uh
just in this opening the whole c4 e4 by
white allowing this e7e5
to my
way of thinking that was just
giving black an easy equality
i mean you're still
there's this question of a half tempo
i'm a bit uh you know saddened by this
but uh black actually doesn't equalize
every single i mean it's not going to be
horrible but it's sometimes a little bit
annoying and i'm very happy that mvl
chose not to play a5 there because i
think it gives us a chance of a less
balanced game i think right keeping an
opportunity for an imbalance yeah if you
if you allow before even though yeah
after b6 the structure remains rock
solid and uh e45 was uh
well you know in terms of our viewing
pleasure and they're really not obliged
to you know you're not playing for our
benefit yeah thinking
thinking of that is not their first
priority but uh on the other hand this
is a blitz game no matter how you know
dull and symmetrical it might look by
move ten might move 35 we're very likely
to have something that will fight
g2 g3 again a questionable move in my
mind apologies
bishop g4 h3 bishop h5 you're going to
have to play g4 or to break that down
i'm not sure i mind that much because
the bishop g6 will be very very cut off
i
also bishop b2 solves that like i play
street page 5 then i play bishop 2 and i
claim that i'm i'm okay with those
developments you can also just continue
with the h4 after that
yeah i think that's that's not horrible
um 94 yeah i would like to see this
piece taken off the board because once
again i've won structure changes i
barely barely want
some kind of a structure change right
knight takes d4 c5 takes d4
here i'm playing knight d7 i'm a bit
surprised by castles though i will say
because now we can actually play bishop
g4 and break more hp yeah and breaking
from that being is surprisingly annoying
you might have to go be three bishop
takes d4 and i think taking on default
with the bishop and we also know what
you plan mvl will be a lot happier about
right
h2h3
allows knight takes f3 check and that's
what uh you've been mentioning peter
that it's suddenly not so easy to break
this pin and bishop e3 takes d4
you you kind of have to because what
else are you supposed to do about the
pin right
right this moment maybe you can include
bc5 because right this moment it might
be forcing black to recapture with the b
pawn if black wants to preserve the
setup in the center because dc5 i think
i have might take c5 i'm not fair fair
fair but bcbc it's not horrible for
black at all i'm ready to challenge on
the b file as well he's gone for that
and vl could of course if he wants to
take with the g-pawn could take on f3
but i don't think i'm really
relinquishing the pin on my own i think
i'm always recapturing with the people
and once again we're back to the
question what are we doing
uh about this setup i think we kind of
shrug and go bishop to hd4 see the xd495
and we hope it's not horrible it
probably probably isn't but
this is not but it's uh it just feels
like black is the one with the
initiative and that
and
just to give you an update furuja right
now against caruana has a much superior
position so he might be clinching the
title with a victory if nvl loses in
this one and that's to say with four
rounds to go oh yes i was always very
proud of myself whenever i won a
tournament with a round to spend i'm
absolutely certain
with four rounds to spare no if if ereza
wins
mvl's result no longer matters because
maybe four and a half ahead even in the
worst case with four hours it is the
five four seconds
so yeah yeah well for him it's a very
very simple equation if he wins this
yeah indeed a very much preferable
position against fabio fabi has done
something suspect out of the opening
there
he's just he's just home and drawing
knight a2 by jeffrey is an indication
that something has
very very seriously gone wrong i mean
he's trying to preserve some life in the
position by not trading more pieces but
that knight on a2
i'm a bit
okay i guess maybe a5 a4 and then root
b5 why it could establish a foothold on
the b5 square i was very interested in
the idea of playing a7 a5 and killing
off that
i loved your a5 move and in case of a4
go 98
welcome rook b5 with knight c7
you know come to me
yes
i think that was a good good idea quincy
quincy eight is i think an indication
that knight d7 knight c5 is always
always on on our mind here if we play
this picture with the black the c5 is by
far the best square on the board exactly
and i don't want to uh
just
linear but linear does have a tremendous
advantage against nepal i've said that
before if i finished it hopefully i will
not use it right position is quite
simple i have to say no no reason to
have to eat your words there um
again this knight on a2 makes all the
difference in the world it's just such a
bad piece
i'm thinking also the knight on f3 peter
but where is the knight on f3 where's
jeffrey's knight i'm not sure where you
are where is police is supposed to go um
honestly i understand because of the
tournament situation and the general
kind of outlook i understand why he
wanted to you know quote unquote keep
the position complicated right but that
knight should have been on d5 and traded
off the board a long while ago it's it's
yeah why is it on a2 it's just
it's horrible on a2 and the other one
will be on c5 in a moment so it's a it's
bad from both viewpoints okay uh
preparation for knight c5 he just wants
to double
the protect the uh
the rook on b6 yeah uh the the wish 27
is
arguably the worst piece he has so
bishop on g2 i hate that so
h3 king h2 h
h3
you know get rid of that ugly looking uh
or at least attempt to because the queen
is still on c8 you know at the end of
all that if there is no knight on d7
which page three is still unplayable so
okay
um
undesirable exchange on b6 but at least
we have a clear pl path
to the d5 square yeah a3 is hanging for
the time being so you you probably need
to spend and i think this is why uh mvl
took ab6 because it's shockingly
unannoying to protect the pawn a3 and
he's just giving it so much so he just
said i
forget about it everything else was
running into knight c5 was tremendous
for us for black so yeah so rook a3
queen b2 perhaps yeah we go through
five i guess yeah 95
knight c5
bishop e2 yeah i don't know pawn d3
looks like knight c5 seems
i guess he thinks knight b3 will cover
everything so he he is not worried
yeah bishop b6 is logical because we're
kind of hinting at bishop takes d5 in
particular if c takes d5 is not a move
you can yeah now i think i am taking
definitely i think i am quite happily
taking him playing b6 my b5 queen b2
though i thought black was just
completely winning by taking on g5
forcing he takes d and then playing b5
bishop b6 and so on but queen b2 there
is a bit annoying i see
you can start with b5 but remains
annoying
you know in some ways this is such a bad
position for black but white part me
bishop takes d5 e takes d5 knight c5
even that is not a very nice bishop
the opposite color uh i'm just looking
for more yeah i know i would like to get
more here with black i would like to uh
to absolutely squeeze uh squeeze
everything out of this because you you
and i think this is a c5
on the board no yeah he's played knight
c5 without trading on d5 even which is a
bit surprising to me because now white
can play as we keep on indicating like
some plan of h4 followed by
and the rook will go to b5 and perhaps
ensure that white at least can recapture
on d5 for the peace
so
this is somewhat surprising to me but i
mean the evaluation remains the same
exactly black is a reasonably healthy
pawn now queen a5 this is also a bit a
bit surprising because he played rugby
five i would instantly go rugby one
check on queen a3 here oh with pleasure
yeah
yeah okay one i have to wonder if you're
supposed to play rugby one but that's
admission of some mistake yeah yep yep
he he picked on up on it right away but
queen a3 i love that move queen a3 or
queen a5
queen a5 does that intimate queen e1
check
possibly but why it is not going to like
bishop f1 is probably happening or h4 is
probably happening exactly against most
of the things you can think of in this
position here queen a5 i'm i'm playing
h4 here this needs to be
included um
you
it's gonna be difficult to win it's so
it's an absolutely two-way street here
white either loses this or makes a draw
white pretty much never ever plays for a
win in this game anymore but winning
this with black will be um
non-trivial
it'll be work
yeah for sure
uh
because of that
it's just very very ugly quinny one
trying to sing bishop h3 yeah certainly
well sort of right because queenie two
will still well that was the eternal pin
right that's that's a very very long
term pin for sure yeah so i guess we
play queen e2 right now right and black
plays
i have a feeling he wants to okay queen
before is a
sort of same but different right he does
realize he needs to
get the queens off and yeah bishop d7
followed by b5
and bishop to a5 it'll take it'll take a
long time but generally speaking you
would assume black eventually wins this
because white runs out of space you you
will have to
um you know the king will go the long
way around yeah he even starts with king
of fate seemingly because there's no way
for white to protect against the threat
of b6b5 exactly so you you don't have to
play it immediately guys i feel we need
some relief for
dominguez maybe we can watch him win a
game oh
that would be so nice it would and where
are we where is the because this one is
going to be a long end game right for
black to try to win it but
lanier might actually get his first
victory in the british wow and the pawn
is on c2 ready to promote one is on c2
and we go i guess king is six king d6
yeah king is six and then queen e3 bish
before
kunjif ah this is a cute little move
because we want to take on before we
check it doesn't help very much though
we can actually play king e7 queen
before king g7 and then the chance to be
safe run out of chat run out eventually
i would assume
but shockingly there's still something
going on yeah like a time 20 seconds
against 17 15 seconds honestly he is
he's not finding it he's still thinking
so he's having seven yeah
queen before king yeah he's liking the
seven queen g4 check
there is still no immediate solution i
think we may have yeah we've been
kind of worried about jinxing him but
yeah quincy for check there is still no
immediate solution
this is terrible
i i feel so bad right now
and three seconds make a move please
please yes
that was made with one second on the
clock yeah and then queen a4 he this
will be a draw now after quincy for
check i think no just
repetition
you can't claim in a blitz game though
it's very difficult to claim i think
because you're you you don't really know
what's going on here you think when 26
is winning or win the six is winning yes
i mean it's not that clear right yeah
but now i play with something like
quincy two or quincy three and uh or
queenie one check even i don't know if i
like winning one chat but
those seconds are ticking fast
bishop
bishop
and queen d1 that's this this is finally
actually which might actually yeah the
checks have run out and queen d1c1 will
happen yeah linear is and i think linear
finally knows rook c8 is a way to
continue but
yeah there are no checks after c1 queen
yeah you can't do that from c
or anywhere oh queen d6 and there's the
handshake bravo linear bravo bravo smile
from linear i'm gonna jump back to the
jeffrey jean game again this is a big
big fight for second place
taking place here
by the way should for ali riza win
this uh game for this round uh that
clinches a victory for him
so maybe we'll also uh pause to
acknowledge
uh simply
yeah let's go let's go
all right if we had time to cover it
it's a probably an actually an
instructive rook ending i think this
might be over yeah it looks like it's
just yeah you take one pick up the pawn
on e3 yeah that's just completely
resignable the pawn wins yeah
congratulations to the young man and and
he wins the tournament yeah have a
champion that is he is our champion
bravo
first place and 13 grand chester points
and 40 000 yeah
he elites
frogs over uh wesley so 25 25 g60 points
yeah yeah just very very comfortably
currently in the lead mvl could still
overtake him if mvl finishes second but
how is mvl doing vls doing
whoa the h pawn is somehow gone from the
board how does that happen why it isn't
even worse why it might be oh it's just
going to be a draw yeah
you think like f29 g4 like okay and i
and then you want but whenever you go h5
i go bishop g5
yeah i don't think you can get in
progress after that but it's a bit it's
a bit about how did he lose his h-bomb
yeah it's a bit of a shocker that this
is the position remarkable
i mean at some point you have to go h5
and just ask the question right
sorry my apologies i didn't have this
game on my yes but bishop g5 is yeah
here we have it
well i really thought that uh
the problem is
in the background and that's an easy
draw
you never allow the knight to twist yeah
i think he's safe but still it's a bit
of a it's a bit of a shocker to see uh
you know that he's having to work uh
now the knight goes to d1 so he tricked
him a little bit
and
and nothing
and the dead end and the door was closed
bishop c1 controls b2 score very nicely
yeah okay yeah i'm not even sure it was
too much of a risk yeah i think jeffrey
understands that i'm not sure
it seems like mvl is ready to yeah will
is claiming and i think it's probably a
correct claim and uh yeah jeffrey isn't
good what do we have left we have ikaru
versus shaq yeah there's still this
going on with uh how's our pineapple
express doing uh
fighting for a draw uh fighting for a
draw fighting for a draw yeah uh
probably should hold this position but
it's never entirely easy with this with
these types of uh
yeah those are some hercules
whoa
uh check and then go somewhere knight h6
check on tap no wait what i think he's
arguing a rep yeah i think he's he's
claiming claiming a repetition there i
would assume
otherwise that gesture doesn't make very
much sense he's trying to close
repetition 97 he says it's a repetition
so one
definitely two
but with the rook on b3
that's a strange no it's it's it's on f3
and oh it's on f3 yeah i apologize he's
right
he's right he's right yeah i checked it
after king g2 king g6 97 97 is probably
the third the third time yeah yes
yeah it does look like it they got it in
the last like 15 moves but they actually
got it three times
yeah
so hikaru hikaru saves this game we
assume but uh it's not a victory he
would have needed to uh to stay in touch
with uh with mvl for instance right
or catch up to mbl i would like to i
mean vl did not win his game so there's
still i think half a point distance
between uh
mvl and hikaru and jan actually lost so
jan drops back to jan should have
claimed
juan should have claimed even if it
wasn't a three-fold repetition he should
have claimed it's a minute uh
bonus for
for lanier yes
we're discussing the situation in the uh
nippon
uh dominguez game where yeah it feels
like there may have been a threefold
along the way somewhere it almost felt
like a five-fold actually it seemed like
both players could have claimed it
two moments
let me check so it's one definitely
to
no that's a different position actually
um there may not have actually been a
three-fold there at least on my screen
it's difficult to judge from yeah it's
only a two-fold it's it's only twofold
from a practical standpoint you do
probably like it's plus cv to claim you
have to do it yeah it's plus cv to claim
but on the other hand i think jan also
recognizes that
you know it's uh
i don't want to i don't want to put put
words in his mouth in his mouth but it's
it's a kind of a weird spot because he's
been lost for so long and like it's just
you know trying to a little bit perhaps
of an angle shoot and nobody likes
both players have been waiting for the
arbiters to confirm that knight e7 was a
three-time repetition i saw that carol
was in the back there and
making that determination and
hikaru was
right
that is the correct call because we see
the result on our screens the game has
been uh announced drawn and that's the
end of the round
with once again congratulations
congratulations to alireza ferrugia who
very very convincingly wins the
saint louis raven blitz 2022 with four
rounds to spare that's four rounds i
have to say this might actually be the
most dominant performance of any super
gm in a rapid and blitz event well we
mentioned the magnus carlsen yes in
india the tournament didn't finish with
four rounds to spare this is what i'm
saying uh-huh
yeah we were we would need like he
scored 27 out of 38. he scored more
points but there was somebody behind him
you're sure i mean
somebody scoring 27 probably wins with
some rounds to spare but yeah i don't
remember the details of that tournament
precisely enough to be able to uh to be
able to say uh alireza will not be able
to to score like if he wins the rest he
gets the 26 and a half i think which is
you know sounded like a bit of a joke
before the round that they started but i
think he's on four and a half out of
five so yeah
so you know i do remember one of the
most unfunny joke uh i mean linares
obviously uh anatoly karpov winning
his lennar's event with i don't care a
3000 dpr but i seem to remember linares
that was a double round robin where like
gary beat every
player in the event once
drew
the other game and nobody else won it
was like everybody just went like minus
one against gary that was a very very
nice for us so for all of us you know
symmetry enjoyers
it was a very symmetrical final wow
and also he has seemingly well not
seemingly overtaken
in the live ratings he's winning 86
rating points
he is currently three uh 2.2 points
ahead of uh hikaru he is 28.81 wow and
hikaru is only totally 26 28 78.8 yeah
paul 328
our congratulations there you see
alireza in the blitz section 11 and a
half points to hikaru's 10 points why
that's why ali reza has overtaken hikaru
in the light with sorry yeah
and honestly with four rounds to go and
he doesn't feel like a person who really
takes his foot off the gas the way he's
playing you know maybe we were talking
about the wrong person teaching 2900 you
know yes yes that's exactly the case
uh we're going to take a short break and
we'll see on the other side
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end has
established itself as a premier global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments including the u.s
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the u.s and world chess halls
of faith
cutting edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art innovative programming
explores the intersection of chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries
the world chess hall of fame is nothing
you expect and everything you love three
different galleries and a premier gift
shop highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game come visit
play chess leave enriched to learn more
about the st louis chess campus visit
stlchestcampus.org
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
welcome back four rounds to go and we
have we have our winner but we don't
have our podium yet uh yeah theresa is
on 22 out of uh 22 and a half out of the
possible
uh
i've lost track
32 points
i'm guessing it's difficult but at this
at this stage uh
on course to potentially be the second
best performance in the gct event with
this formula
behind only magnus is 27 points out of
36 in uh kolkata in 2019 a tournament
we've looked it up in the break uh
magnus scored 27. hikara was second was
23.
four-point game yeah and then a tie for
third between i believe anish and wesley
was on 18 and a half points so there was
a gap yeah nobody nobody else was really
much in the running there apart from
those two gentlemen but in this
particular case we have a big fight for
second place peter absolutely and these
are your pairings for round 15. uh sam
shanklin is playing against reza uh
yanni pomnish is white against caruana
uh chef plays against devon and this
pairing looks looks tasty yeah i think
we're sticking with uh
the game between maximo shirley krav and
hikaru nakamura which is very very
crucial in the fight for second and
third and we also have the mingus
against jefferson and there you have the
hearty hand clasp
as another mother of modern defense and
hikaru
is
looking for a fight
i want to say gnashing of teeth a little
snarly
definitely looking for a fight yeah we
can we can have a kings indian now if we
want to with the move c2 c4 but i get
the feeling yeah we're not going to get
the king's indian h3 i think an
indication that mvl wants to play the
bishop d3 systems
against f6 against knight f6 i would
assume even though knight c3 is still a
very very legitimate move there by the
way guys we do have a kings campaign
king's gambit hooray i was waiting when
this was you know this was
bound to happen at some point in this
tournament jan
famously recorded uh a contractually
obliged course for chessable and he
picked king's gambit he did and recorded
a very very nice instructive course on
the opening and has won some very nice
games with it since so it's clearly uh
it's clearly a playable opening if you
invest some time into it and also if
your opponents don't i think that would
be
that would be the way to describe it
it's not great but which they don't know
yeah
which they don't yes
c5 uh
taking advantage i want to say
rather the soft
h2h3 as well this looks completely fine
for black i i played a lot of beards in
my in my younger years and
this would be like i would
yeah i'd sign up for this one as well
yeah it it looks more like a sicilian
now but it's a very true sicilian you
uh where would you put your b8 knight by
the way would you be going d7
b5 bishop b7 yeah e6 i think this is the
setup you you would like to get the
question is like in which order you go
for it because if you play 97 after a4
you're not getting b5 if you start with
b5 you have to consider e45 ideas you
have to maybe consider whoa whoa
that was definitely not on high no that
might be good yeah not on my bingo card
but you know it makes a decent amount of
sense actually stopping before five dead
in its tracks we want to play bishop six
knight bd7 uh
yeah i like very but this
and some other things
um hp69 g5 is a bit awkward in
particular in considering that he
probably feels he needs to play for a
win and yeah h6 is
generally needed but also you kind of
regret spending a tempo on that i think
right
nice okay he's a little bit worried that
a4 a5 mission b6
could
batten down the queen side so knight c6
to take away a5 maybe on a good day we
can establish the knight on b4
absolutely i'm interested in queen g2
and then perhaps in some cases taking
away the b4 square i will maybe be
playing 95 later but all of these are
very very double edged we can also play
bishop d3 c4 right now which is maybe
not that stupid
um as an option but yeah and i think
this is what he's done but knight a5
knight c4 might be a reasonable reply to
it
knight a5 honestly knight c4 yeah
weirdly i want to say the bishop on g7
is not an upgrade on the neither of
bishop on a7 hikaru disagrees hikarius
goes bishop b6 says the structure is
to my liking right now because i think
if you take on e6 and yeah mbl declines
it will be very very difficult for white
to stop d65 from happening very quickly
with the rook coming to g8 and g65
push of course is much improved by the
presence of the pawn on e6 not the
bishop knight a5 now we do play 25 yeah
absolutely uh eyeballing the c5 c4
square h7h6 he really wants to stop
knight g5 i can i can definitely get
behind that idea okay
queen d2 i guess we're looking at h7
yeah
81 which which one would you like it's
one of those eternal questions which
rook well the one thing we can
absolutely agree any rook
whichever rook we can
we we can sing the chorus of wrong rook
yes absolutely
he chose the wrong rook and also yeah
rook i was going to say we could already
try playing 95 but i think he wants to
provoke a rook to g8 and then play
knight g5 anyway okay because we would
very much like of course to keep a piece
on d5 and not to take with the pawn i
think we can if we go knight g5 here all
the captures happen and if black plays
knight before at the end of that
variation i think after queen b3 you
cannot take on c2 which means that we've
achieved our you know prime objective of
trading some light pieces establishing a
foothold on the d5 square and and then
you know the plan is to place e3 double
on the g file exert pressure against the
d6 pawn very very comfortable position
for
mvl what peter is talking about is
just
the outpost the d5 square outpost if we
can get rid of
four minor pieces the bishop on e6 the
bishop of b3 knight on c3 knight on f6
then white has
the opportunity to occupy the outpost on
d5 and that's why peter is expecting
knight d5 queenie too peter i liked your
move better full stop yeah i think i
think mvl is playing it a bit too coy
even though maybe he just wants to take
on the fight for the rook maybe like
his point is he is agreeing with the
general direction this is supposed to
take but he wants to be taking on d5 for
the rook like 95 95 exactly
maybe he wants to take on e6 followed by
queen c4 yeah if black does nothing that
will be probably quite tasty if you do
that as well but like some move like
king g8 bishop c4 and queen esa queen c4
um 97 is not asking too much i want to
fight for
a 4a5 is going to be very painful
it's a goo it would have been a very
playable move maybe if not for the fact
that a45 comes in with
uh potentially devastating force for
casey one and bill is doing this very
very slowly i don't think he can get
away with always five and c4
whoa
i was gonna well i just wanted to ask
once again knight e7 and d i don't think
you're stopping d5
yeah
i yeah i think we've uh
uh you know finessed ourselves a little
bit too much here with white i don't
think all of this
is
intricate intricate play was required in
the meantime the king's gambit appears
not to have the best outing in the world
today against fabi
because if i be you know does strike me
as somebody who will prepare himself a
person who will actually check this out
yeah right it's not because of the
opening actually white was doing quite
well at some point
a mistake yeah okay i do remember a game
that lin um
dieter
versus fabi it was an evans gambit and
fabi played like a perfect game and they
almost seemed to refute the evans gambit
and i thought to myself
wow that is great preparation i mean
that you prepared for an evan's gambit
but evans evans is a very serious
opening and it's been uh
like gary played it very seriously as a
repertoire opening in the mid 90s yes
winning uh so if you take on d5 do you
take back with the rook or with the pawn
i think peter's whole point was that you
would like to control the d5 square with
it
right then after route
97 can i just simply get d5 next move i
think you can and i think it takes d5
which is like b4 maybe even though i
don't want to allow you to go c3
yeah knight e7 and then
d5 next
yeah
i like 97 more so that we don't have to
think about getting hit by c2 c3
anywhere agreed
and well we're going backwards i would
like to once again apologize for some
ruptured eardrums there it was
for what some ruptured eardrums
ruptured here
[Laughter]
i was more worried about the incoming
myself
97 uh tickling the rook where am i
putting it
can i go queen c4
oh
he has done it yes you can he is
assuming control here with black upon my
word uh there's no rook c3 that king
by the way furuja 109 no
against sam shanklin no oh
the guy is just in the zone yeah
nobody can stop him
well we know that the question is
whether anyone yeah the question is when
anyone can stop him from reaching 20
2900 by the end of this turn wow
that's a good point yeah okay there i i
spot a
i spot a pussycat here queen takes a4 b3
knight c4
maybe with some hopes because we are
kind of hinting at knight b6 and maybe
the position becomes a bit awkward for
black to handle but we are yeah
searching for
compensation
for compensation for a reasonably
healthy pawn here from black yeah right
so where do you put the queen now
there's a number of options
queen d5 followed by rook c6 but i don't
really like really provoking c2 c4 so
so blatantly
so queen b5 i don't think i want to go
c4 i want to put the knight on c4 and
then i want to play rook c6 and clay
yeah
yeah the queen on b5 doesn't look right
i was very reluctant to even suggest it
i guess we do go to we go queen c6 and
after knight c4 we look for a good move
my issue was i'm not sure what the good
movie do you have a good chance yeah i
mean i have some acceptable moves but
none of them really strike me as
outstanding he's going quincy queen b5
knight 4g knight b6 ge4 very clever by
higaro
watching sporting yet another little
tactic there using the pin hang on takes
ah rook d2 rook takes it to everything
comes out okay that's some reading
excuse me that was uh my my mouse slip
take on d5 is on the board
take on d5 yes he's on the board okay
i'm guessing he will take with the
knight i think he took away sorry
although he's going to actually refresh
my board first rook actually also works
yeah that i mean once you play the move
d5 and untangle
it does feel like a very healthy pawn
yeah it's just a very very healthy uh
extra point for guitar and also half a
minute on the clock in this position so
yeah i think his favorite to win and
this is a very very big result in the
context of the the fight for second
absolutely
uh making making the whole thing much
more alive bishop b6
yeah yeah
jan actually will at least not lose
so the king the kings got better yeah
yeah the king's gambit rides again yeah
very very nice let's see
don't say that twice
kings gave it right yeah we're trying to
be good examples for the youngsters
exactly exactly
we we try to keep this as an educated
show
it's a family show i understand
it's a family show i should not be
promoting violence
queen c6 ideas of knight f4 he's gone
like the fourth first and then okay 97
uh trying to yeah bishop b8 is a kind of
a cutesy little move attacking
everything but i mean queen ah yeah
actually 26 that's a good move f6 yeah
you have to you have to protect
everything but this uh you know severely
hampers your your own bishop on
uh
g7 96 b5
um
look is still better but it feels like
maybe you've got some chances queen a8
yeah the issue is if the if if we
abandon the long diagonal and the black
queen suddenly finds itself on the long
diagonal we get mated
yeah yeah yeah so something like night
check and
queens because you can't take on a5
queen six is basically made yes uh king
h2 a4 a4 yeah and then c4 so and vl will
keep the queen on a8 for as long as
possible uh because he needs it okay i
mean if if d5 becomes available you
prefer g5 now before queen b5 maybe but
the a pawn is also very strong this is a
kind of a very weird anime if i've
finally chosen by a male you just take
quite happily i think you know take i
take back with the knight yeah
by the way uh the king's gambit was
drawn yeah this this ended up being a
draw yeah a very very surprising choice
but they seven there in the end whoa yes
that might be a problem yeah queen a
seven any or even a five yeah he is now
completely winning
knight d4
just the full piece and uh
12 seconds should be for for for
somebody like hikaru 12 seconds in this
position should be remarkable a lot of
times
very nicely done by hikaru
wow big fight for second place and uh
oops uh one game remains
uh sort of re-energized by his victory
over uh whoa
i continue continue continuing yeah i
was re-energized i was having happy
about this position and now i no longer
am but maybe maybe i shouldn't be
because he still may be winning because
the a-pawn is queening right three
seconds two make a move rookie two i
think we can queen
i think we can queen but there is also
yeah and then queen g4 check and then
queen takes c2 and that wins the game
yeah so linear wins another one which is
wow nice to see and also very relevant
in our conversation it's definitely
jeffrey was kind of threatening to
hanging because he's become a contender
but with this loss
it feels like maybe it's hikaru versus
specifically mvl and yan
after you've won two games at the worst
event of your entire career you think
where have i been
yeah you feel like you know what why
wasn't i playing like this before for
four and a half days exactly a lot of
victories in that round uh went
went by uh christian absolutely and
let's take a look at uh how furuja
closed the show with another victory
against sam shankland actually sam was
doing quite well out of the opening
maybe borderline winning specifically at
this point after the move bishop to c5
now black is one move away from
finishing his development and then the
quinoa in a6 is going to feel a bit
uncomfortable bishop to b7 was a huge
move right now of course if you do go
castle and sacrifice the exchange then
only one of the players can play for a
victory and that is white if you do go
rook to c7 or rook to b8 i'm going to
follow that up with the move knight to
c6 in fact if you put it on b8 instead
of c7 this is even worse because i can
take with the queen as well but bishop
takes c6 seems to be putting the
blacking on a very precarious uh
situation also the bishop on c5 is
hanging so of course you're losing that
now
bishop to b7 was not found knight to d2
a bit slow allowing uh black to castle
and get into a safe haven with the king
rook to d1 and this was the critical
mistake knight to b3 would have uh given
white quite a decent advantage in the
position specifically because i have so
many targets at some point we're going
to see a lot of exchanging the dark
square bishops are going to be exchanged
once the c file opens up these rooks are
going to be exchanged as well and then
you're going to have to contend with the
weaknesses of the pawn on a7 as well as
the pawn on b4 a bit overextended black
is on the queen side so definitely this
gives the advantage to white rook to d1
and i do believe that he just completely
missed that after bishop takes c3 he
cannot recapture with the knight knight
takes e3 this is a very natural
recapture the problem is that
after one two punch combo i take your
rook you take back i pick up the knight
on d2 you just simply lose a piece you
cannot allow this so
once uh bishop takes e3 came on the
board he realized he has to take with
the f-pawn but this is just ugly uh now
despite of uh of the fact that maybe you
will win upon on the queen side your
king is going to be forever weak and
this is exactly what happened knight to
g4 queen takes a7 a bit too greedy in
this position rook to c7 queen to a4
rook queen to c8 setting up this very
nasty pin on the c file i mean
what can be said about this young man
he's just simply in the zone right now
not giving his opponents any chances and
just simply winning game after game very
very impressive
uh thank you for that christian as we
look at our current standings
peter higaron clear second now with the
with mvl uh stumbling and higher winning
uh and there's a we
can take one of two courses yeah either
continue singing him praises which is
entirely deserved or just say yeah
we know uh please could you you know
stop he's already dead comes to mind uh
uh and we all have a point behind from
uh hikaru and yani punishing half a
point behind from uh behind the wheel
and then uh jeffrey and charlie are tied
for a fifth uh on 16 and a half points i
see in the blitz that fabi and lavonne
aren't doing that terribly but well
their scores yeah they're in the second
half of the tournament peter that's not
great
and we're going to take a very very
short break and we'll be back for the
remaining rounds
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the last three
rounds of the blitz where we definitely
know the winners as you can see they're
five and a half points
ahead of the field that got clinched
yeah hikaru is now in clear second the
only half a point by half a point the
only two people who have uh above ten
points double digits in the blitz yes
out of the 15 games played alireza is on
a barely credible 12 and a half out of
15 and he carries an 11 out of 15. uh
mvl isn't clear third yanipo machine
clear fourth and then there is a type of
fifth between uh jeffrey
and the all-american contingent there at
the bottom are not really having a great
tournament no
and on this showing
might not actually overtake wesley in
the dc standings
whoa and
therefore let's take a look at our uh
pairings
and how important for the gct standings
this game between lavon irony and mvl
truly is because not only about
physically but grand chester sorry peter
please yeah absolutely i'm very much in
agreement with you i think uh levon has
had a very very quiet day today in
particular not really doing all that
well
every time he doesn't do well in a blitz
tournament i kind of
wonder what's going on because in my
mind he is one of the absolute best in
the world uh in this format but he is
definitely not playing struggling uh not
playing as well as he uh has done
purusha versus shaq
intriguing game but again we're looking
at this fight for second
kara nakamura with his half a point lead
he's playing against lanier but
he's playing a different lanier yeah
just won two games in a row peter
for all of us you know
we we all like and respect lanier a
great deal yes he's had an absolute
nightmare until i mean he's
if we're honest with ourselves he still
has a nightmare yes but it's it's a
nightmare which is more
doable
at least he won a couple of nice games
in a row which
does bring some light
uh to his mood and when he's playing
well he is definitely a match for for
for anyone in this tournament absolutely
and again our marquee matchup for this
round would be lavon with a beautiful
sartorial
shirt and uh and notice it's a long
sleeve shirt which is a no-no i mean
we've talked about the unrestricted
uh you want to play blitz you want to
make new moves quickly
and
short sleeve is the way to go so a
little surprising by levon
a little bit but he is uh you know he
knows his uh
capabilities and he he knows when he
needs to go that extra mile by by
placing playing in like a i believe i've
seen him play like you know hello kitty
t-shirts and things of that nature
that's that's i think when he feels he
feels he needs that extra two percent i
think
yeah i think that was also very much
like a
a bit of a bird fleet towards the the
the dress code peter was trying to
impose in that tournament hello kitty it
was over the top
that got that drew the ire of the fide
presidential board
probably yeah
nice nice hello kitty
okay
i'm gonna have to
take another uh gander my wardrobe i'm
wondering why i'm yeah so behind the
times
and they're off with the trump yeah did
you play a lot of rapid and blitz
tournaments yourself there wasn't
a lot of a rapid i love both
formats i really really did
but uh unfortunately there was just not
enough
events
they didn't exist
it does feel like they just started
right right this past decade maybe like
2012 2013 is when they start they really
became established i want to say within
the last 10 yes uh 15 years but up to
that moment i mean we
you talk about bobby fischer think of
his extraordinary
history uh career history and tell me
how many blitz tournaments he won yeah
i don't have that in front of me yeah
but you you remember the famous one in
yugoslavia where he just he just
outclassed the entire field with victor
korchnoy and michael tall the clash of
the century whatever book it was on and
that was one
yeah not energy that's just more than
that that's it there just weren't any
events to play that's it that was my
problem there just wasn't enough at the
events
okay peter while you're doing a course
on the trump office yeah
i keep on wondering why
they're not tell us what what we should
know about the trump yeah this is
already not exactly what uh what what
the chorus gives and i think against
once again i'm pretty sure i'm giving c4
e5 and this is the second game in this
tournament where c45 is not a choice of
a very strong player and generally
speaking i would trust mvl with opening
theory what you would say is exactly
here c4 c4 e5 yeah that's what you're
trying to see that's what you're trying
to i think so i'm i'm forced on the uh
trompos
i still haven't returned to it and
looked but yeah i think this is what i i
would recommend this i very much like
for white i have to say because we'll
play either knight g2 on knight f3 and
in this particular structure i think
there's definitely an argument for
putting the knight on e2 because its
ideal square i think is h5
and you want to be aiming towards it as
directly as possible exactly uh so you
know g2 castle's castle will put the
knight on either g3 or f4 and we'll
continue hinting that there's something
not exactly you know not quite right
with your structure there dear sir the
f6 pawn should shift itself to g6 so we
understand it's illegal but
you try to get in one or two illegal
moves each and every tournament
exactly exactly d4g5 here
maybe he wants to play e6 maybe it's not
that horrible i do like that
very much
d4d5 yeah
yeah d5v6 i'll take it and queen b3 and
rookie one yeah queen b6 the end games
will be fine uh queen b6 yeah i don't
have i don't have queen b6 sometimes you
have that black blackout right the queen
on a5 was defending f5 defending h5 and
queen b6 right but i think mvl is
showing a very very uh
clear understanding that he cannot play
quietly he cannot just allow white to
get the setup i was describing so he
played indeed he played a 596 very very
early on trying to stop the knight from
landing on h5 and now g5 v6 is the is
the right way to play you can go rookie
one here but then after okay g8 you
might actually lose that pawn
so you
so at this point you probably just have
to take yeah i think we think okay go
queen b3 and queen b6 23 b6 yeah it's
just fine for black i think it looks
perfectly fine
is such a monster but uh take on e6 and
then just double trouble rookie
is going to be three first first we can
still play queen b6 obviously but maybe
white preserves some sort of uh
flexibility so what's the difference are
you going to actually try to go d6
yourself no no i think we're keeping it
on d5 for the time being like takes
takes rook fv1
just because you can never take on d5
actually we can i mean if if we actually
do that knight takes d5 i i will have
bishop takes between the end i'm not
that unhappy about those whole things
b6 is on the board yeah take stakes for
q1 i think has been played already and
now the question will uh will come up
if you don't like that i think there's
nothing wrong with rookie 8 here i don't
think we are obliged to start
calculating anything at all here
uh yeah and this is what mvl chooses
says uh yeah
my position is perfectly fine i don't
need to be trying to solve non-existent
problems by tactical means basically
sometimes that the ghosts can do it for
you rook a12 d1 king f7 might be five
from eg8 i don't know that's risky a 96
check is still awkward there
um
i mean he's
fishing trying to
find a
promising square for the rook
yeah if you want to be extra safe you
can play bishop g7 f8 piercing i think
solves
all of the you know future and current
problems you could ever have here with
black but i think the long diagonal is
maybe not the most attractive thing in
the world but it does cover so many
squares most especially d6 which is rook
was threatening the exactly to the land
a2 a3 releasing the knight uh we don't
have to worry about rook takes a2 in
such circumstances yeah but now knocking
f7 knight b5 you'll just go rook 88 or
eg8 whichever one he prefers
you start slightly preferring black here
i guess because the bishop will be quite
potent on c5 and uh i was thinking uh
the my follow-up to knight b5 might be
to play b2b4 precisely because of what
you're about to say the bishop on c5
will will have found a lovely outpost
where do i put the knight on g3
yeah the knight had a role
long a long time ago but now like do i
go knight two knight f4 do i go knight
to knight d4 it just doesn't feel yeah
it starts with knight
but then then you have to wonder yeah f4
g3 how with 92 is you allow e5 exactly
yeah
yeah then you can try to hook that pawn
with knight c1 id3 or things of that
nature but if you give up too much space
to black you're going to be in trouble
by the way i don't know if the black's
last move introduced bishop takes a3
definitely but uh knight g3 to stop the
threat yes
yeah you definitely prefer black here
but it it shouldn't really have left the
the sort of the margins of equality just
yet but right with the with the pawn
center
you're kind of feeling like black's
pieces have more space
king's a little bit more active maybe
the bishop it's because they do yeah
yeah yeah that's how it works for that
very straightforward reason yeah
is winning again my goodness uh you were
laughing uh peter as we were coming on
break because you were looking at the
live standings and you're just shaking
your head in disbelief about the ratings
because it was close to uh yeah plus 100
ratings yes
is gaining almost 100 points and also
despite him winning his previous game he
is now behind hikaru again because
hikaru has beaten the higher rated
opponent
by a fraction yeah alireza has beaten uh
uh
and hikaru uh beats uh mvl mvl and uh he
kind of gained more points with that
victory and hikaru is now
0.0.8 points
above but he's worse against dominguez
firmly in first
the whites
but yeah hikaru is somewhat struggling
against lanier where uh whereas uh
anireza is in control against shahrier i
mean it's a sharp position for a blitz
game but
doing well rook d wanted to see one an
indication that not all is well
with levon's position bishop h6 yeah
he's having to play passively but yeah
it's very difficult for blood to
generate any uh significant threats and
they they've been kind of shuffling i
don't think mvl i think we're just going
to see a repetition
yeah says mvl says i don't have much
that's a repetition so let's switch to
perhaps the hikaru yeah either the
hikaru game or the uh ferrous game let's
go to firuja just because i think he's
putting the finishing touches oh yeah
now he is winning yeah okay this is
probably he actually won yeah
this one is also over so he
and shah i think might be high rated
enough for the reza a resident
definitely will be within a game to
getting to 2900 yes whereas hikaru is
uh up against lanier yeah and i think no
matter what happens in this one giveaway
has a much higher rating than
he's winning less points
if he wins this one so
might be on the live ratings the highest
rated chess player in the blitz section
yeah e5 will be played i don't think uh
hikaru is doing that poorly actually the
bishop on b2 is sort of stupid but
so so is the bishop on g7 now and by the
way there is a potential for rook takes
d4 keep
yeah
uh the question
can we is on d4 we probably can
seems to me i think i spotted a pond uh
got myself all excited there yeah i
think what do you take with rook with a
rook okay yeah just so that i don't
allow bishop takes d4 rook d7 yeah we
don't want to cause an accident we don't
want to get pinned yeah you still have
to calculate things there obviously yes
you know it seems to be available and if
it's available you're very very
incentivized of course with why to do it
because breaking breaking up that uh
that central chain is hugely important
and just the fact that uh lanier did not
answer it i was about to say instantly
it was an indication that oops i think i
just blundered upon yeah it feels like
this was missed and uh i mean the
position remains kind of unclear right
she takes a four because
um
exactly
rook g8 queen f4 why this actually white
is now like firmly in control it feels
like rook takes d a followed by queen
takes a four stops stop squinting to
check white traverse d2 i mean it's and
the white king is probably the safer one
of the two so you're you're also covered
yeah black's king
on h8 hiding behind the bishop but yeah
we'll see we'll see what hikaru chooses
there's a number of things you can do
here
i like your rook d8 he just goes gf says
i don't really need to uh calculate it i
mean
just to say yeah roger king h1 i guess
he just says i have i have nothing to
fear here i'm a bit worried about this
i'd be i'd be very
very reluctant to go for positions like
like cd focus seven queen h4 or
something it this king on schwa
does not inspire you know as much
confidence as maybe some agreed agreed
in some other cases i'm this is a very
brave decision for a blitz game i would
be very very very much above that
yeah you're ripping 20 seconds though 10
seconds against a minute you get the
feeling that this might eventually be
maybe they're telling
the telling factor i've got to deal with
queen f2 uh here queen of two queen of
four there's a bunch of very very
important threats yeah i don't like i
don't like what he calls you should
probably start calculating e6 right
which you go yeah e6 you can h3 or queen
of two yeah whichever one you prefer
your queen of two
yeah queen g queen takes a four simply
yeah
followed by bishop to e5 you're going to
have to deal with yeah
[Music]
that was not right this is not a good
thing no no no that was not true
black should not be worse but this is
not this is not how you play for a win
here yeah for sure
yeah you have to take on g7 there is no
choice king takes is much stronger than
rook takes yeah black is fine but i'm
pretty sure uh black has significant
winning chances a bit uh you know just
just a tiny tiny moment ago he's seven
rookie eight it's just a very very cool
position
yes of course it is
yeah hikaru will continue playing
because
the clock yeah the clock basically but
yeah
without the clock this is there's just
nothing here to discuss whatever e5 yeah
feels like black slightly slightly
better
i mean
nobody's really better but
yeah i can i can understand yeah i can
understand yeah i don't know yeah hikaru
is sort of trying to make this into a
double h position but yeah like this is
how you lose this with white right not
really how you know it's not that
difficult to lose it electricity
this is clever this that was a very very
okay
you're definitely not losing this
anymore you're actually
you have significant winning chances now
with white
well yes but
by the way breaking uh
news fabiano did win his game
yeah that was a very very clever uh
clever thing that that hikaru did there
and now he'll just go rugby 100 g7 and
eventually
that's the sort of the winning plan but
i don't know if it's good enough it
might still be a draw but
yeah he's also he has half a minute
against eight seconds which is a very
very telling factor here so the idea is
to go h6 yeah and then eventually the
the rook will land on on g7 yeah
whoa okay what was that
ah okay so actually going afterwards
he's actually going after the a5 pawn
yeah this is very clever
yeah this is good by goodbye but okay
five king before right yeah very good
recognition i should maybe just put it
on yeah just don't don't do that anymore
by the way play it with one second last
move okay five yeah this is this should
and now you go after the h8 square yeah
ah this is clever actually and then uh
and then h6 not that easy anymore
might not be six might not be a draw
anymore
easy what do you mean easy it might be
it might be very easy king f7
and
f7 yeah i mean this is just completely
lost
yeah so
yeah hikaru wins up seemingly a
completely completely drawn rook ending
with ease which is uh why you're
remarkable why you shouldn't have five
seconds for the rest of the game by move
30. wow that was around christian that
went by so fast
uh i heard the results but what did we
miss absolutely well first of all let's
stick with this game because it was
linear who was winning first
in this end game can you believe that
take a look at this
king d4 rook a uh rook h5 rugby seven a4
this was a double question mark move i
can just simply play the move b4 yeah
that is take on a5 i go king c3 and i'm
much faster with a look behind the pawn
this is going to be a losing end game
for white i'm not 100 sure this might
have been a mutual blind spot situation
this a4 b4 uh situation of course after
you take on a4 you're starting to suffer
in that position now this one obviously
went to hikaru we saw what happened in
that one let's take a look at how firuja
won his game against mamedyarov because
this one was an interesting one as well
they got into this position in which it
felt like black mamadiarov that is has
uh full control of the situation the d5
is quite controlled once you play the
move f3 which he did which white did at
some point you have to do something on
this side and put as much pressure as
possible on
the weaknesses in black's structure the
problem is whenever you push this pawn
the f-pawn you're also opening up the
opportunity for black to push on the
king side with the move h5 h4 and take
advantage of the fact that the spawn on
g3 only has one defender left that is
the pawn on h2 of course the knight as
well but you don't have two pawns
defending it so it becomes quite weak
this would have been the best plan for
black h5 h4 and try to checkmate the
white king he did not do that after
bishop to d6 queen to a6 rook to b8 b4
this was the move that just missed a
tempo not only that the bishop was
nicely placed on e6 defending the pawn
on d5 your weakness in the position what
you have to do is just follow up with
that plan and seek the compensation in
the position that would have been after
the move h5 h4 definitely in a blitz
game it does feel like practically black
has great chances to generate enough
compensation on the king side he did not
do that missed a bit with the move
bishop to h3 mama the arrow that is look
to f2 knight to g4 and yes
gift me the other pawn as well a very
nice central pawn you also have to tend
with the fact that e4 e5 is coming and
with such a centralized beautiful knight
on d5 this is going to be a very
difficult defense knight to c3 h5 a
little bit too little too late e4 h4
you're not in time you take on g3 but
now it is me who i'm checkmating you on
the king side knight to f6 a nice
fine at the end to just simplify the
position after g takes f6 i can take on
g6 i take on f6 that's the third pawn in
the position and a very easy end game
after knight takes g4 beautiful uh
beautiful win by alireza i have to say
now let's take a look at what
this was just simply incredible the game
between fabiano and sam shanklin take a
look i'm not going to go through the
whole game but take a look at the end
crazy moment this position right now
after the move rook to c2 what you can
do as black is if you find this check
it's an almost checkmate in the position
white has to go king to g1 you cannot
touch the rook on h3 bishop f4 king to
h1 queen takes h3 rook to h2 queen takes
h2 that's a checkmate in the position so
if you would have found this rook to h3
move came to g1 and now bishop to e3
everything is coming right you cannot go
king to f1 because of rook to h1 you
have to go rook to f2 that's a
completely shattering position for
lack disaster striking definitely in
this one he played the move bishop to f4
king to g1 and queen to h3 right now
you're trying to checkmate me but i'm
first i'm checkmating you first rook to
c7 then the game is over pretty much
king to f8 queen to h8 you go rook to g8
i pick up this one you go king to e8 i
go queen to e7 and that's just a
checkmate so it turned from checkmate
for black to checkmate for white in a
couple of moves a lucky escape i have to
say for fabiano caruana and actually a
very important escape for him because
right now fabiano i think he's on 17
points uh closely behind the third
position maybe we can take a look at the
standings yeah let's take a look uh
alireza is still in full control right
streak
appears to be uh back back to his
winning ways and likely to take second
with two rounds to go and a point
advantage over the third place but then
the fight for third is very very hot
yeah yeah mvl is uh on eighteen uh jan
on seventeen and a half and then there's
a couple of guys on uh tied for fifth
with uh five putting up a bit of a
streak there i think he was a victory
yeah
yeah no that that was huge that was
blunderful peter yes that was uh ooh
you have to assume they had like three
seconds exactly exactly you don't see
those kinds of blunders and again
uh stealing those grand chess tour
points uh peter yes we we have a wild
card here doing extremely well and
jeffrey as well is going to be taking
taking some some points out of the
ecosystem for sure but right yeah hikaru
is doing the most damage there uh no
question that's that's ten points yeah
that's like three points go on going out
of the race right um we'll see what
transpires ali reza is gonna jump past
uh wesley it looks like mvl is going to
jump past as well
and is lavon going to do it unclear he's
uh he's won his last game i believe but
he is still in a
weird kind of in between a bubble yeah
he he pro if he if he scores two out of
two in the last round sure one and a
half might be enough one out of two i've
ventured to say probably isn't i see
and as we get ready for our ultimate uh
round uh
who do you like in terms of our marquee
matchup as well
let's take a look let's take a look
let's take a look at the pairings so you
can make a determination for us peter
yeah normally you would want the game
between mvl and fiorogia but
[Music]
i think the choices between this and
nipple machine and kamura both are you
know very very nice uh mvl isn't a spot
where i don't think you can play
either the berlin draw i think his fight
his fight for third is
you know hitting up enough that he can't
really coast
i think we'll have to stay with that one
with the furushot game just because
first if he wins this one passes 2900
yes and also that yeah i wanted to bring
up the fact that they both won both
euroja and nakamura one and ferocious
has overtaken the number one spot by 0.6
uh zero strength of competition
and they they're both on 2894 with
virgil also having those ultra ultra
special 0.6 points
i'm looking at your monitor peter i'm
seeing 99.6
rating points
yes wow what a failure not even winning
100 but a failure uh remarkable i
geez
who who does that in that one tournament
who wins 110 points i mean k20 is a hell
of a drug but uh still
even even with that that is really
really remarkable what he's doing in
this tournament yeah we thought his
rapid result was good but yeah this is
just uh crazy crazy good so you made a
determination it's the all-french derby
i think we're watching mvl versus
on the screen is mvl and again mvl with
white
um well i mean uh the runner rate uh how
does mvl stop the runaway train
well
you know people if people knew that in
this tournament
they would have been doing it right now
right
but uh yeah i think his situation on 18
points is nowhere near comfortable
enough for him to play it safe and
i don't know it's you you also have to
factor in their personal relationship
and uh they played
with cars reversed yesterday they
definitely played that game
it was the one yeah it was a
full-blooded game and uh yeah
but with mvl on the white side you know
if he goes before uh
i think the ball is sort of an idea
scored if he if there is a goes e5 they
they will have the option but the lesser
has been playing so well in this
tournament that he could just play i
don't know the card for something it's
easy and you know by move one uh mvl
will know that uh the option is taken
away from him and he he has to play i
think for you know for us but also for
himself it's much better for him to try
but uh
you know i'm sitting here in a
comfortable studio i haven't i am yeah i
haven't played 34 games of chess in the
last four and a half days it's very easy
for me to you know
feeling i'm sure the players are a bit
groggy
and we saw that with some
outstanding howlers that that that
wonderful game where sam shanklin just
allowed checkmate
when he should have been the one giving
checkmate uh
yeah that was a very very particularly
egregious so i have a question for you
guys what does such a performance do to
a young man's career and a young man's
confidence
that's huge he will be very very happy
about this but i think this uh
on the list of
i wonder how he feels about it though he
is 19 and uh perhaps he has a slightly
different uh view on these things but
for me
uh he's winning the grand swiss
wow is probably the go-to as you know
the career defining the
so far the career defining moment and
you know it was followed up by an
absolutely crushing performance on board
one in the european teams but that's a
team event it sort of counts
i mean it still of course counts but
it's remembered less as his personal
triumph right even though he absolutely
propelled the french team and like that
allowed him to pass 2800 yeah but then
there was the painful sour of madrid in
the candidates that's uh awesome
he played he played bucharest and did
not really do well there and then went
to the candidates and uh that was really
really painful for you know the his you
know fans yeah the the the fans of each
of which he deservedly has plenty who
expected great things for him in his
first candidates tournament but
uh yeah it's it's a question of
priorities because this is an absolutely
dominant dominant performance against
the absolute you know world creme de la
creme yeah and he looks like a man
that's not interesting in stopping
anytime soon he wants to finish this
tournament with the bank still
absolutely yeah
super focused doesn't talk to anybody i
mean uh
business he is
one he's won
all games with bar one right today he
drew against jan in round one and hasn't
drawn a single game since right i think
is that six and a half hours that's six
and a half out of seven so if he if he
wins the last two
this will be the best ever result in a
single round blitz round robin in the
history of gct of the honor which i
think
i think
yeah which i think belonged to mvl
yeah with eight out of nine you know a
month and a half ago so records really
are there just to be broken i i have the
feeling that we've seen a couple of
seven and a halfs yes
has been achieved yeah yeah i believe
hikaru did it magnus did it but uh eight
and a half yeah i mean that would be
that would be uh by the way
looking at yon's body posture
he doesn't have a look of a man who's
not ready to play the penultimate round
come on guys
hey guys can we can we call it the
explanation exclamation mark posture
check yeah
yeah
also can we please maybe move the camera
away from from like why are we why are
we doing this
i i i didn't know about this but
apparently there was going to be a film
critic for resident evil that he was
going to watch all of the zombie movies
and give his a critique of them okay but
he fell asleep
so he became known as a resident sleeper
yes a resident sleeper young explaining
twitch memes is
not something i expected to happen today
but
right but i'll take it happily
absolutely you've got to know your
resident sleeper when you see one
by the way the man in the blue shirt
kevin murphy out of seattle washington
uh kevin and i grew up
grew up together with the chess world
and he uh helps hikaru uh a great deal
in his career and
kevin likes to make uh the journey to st
louis are they still working together or
i believe so i believe so just a a lot
of assistance in a lot of different
areas hikaru is actually his career is
not just streaming it's writing it's
he does a lot let's just put it that way
and right now
he knows he's got to bear down so let's
take a look at the standings one more
time yeah
where we started
that battle for second and third
position over mdl
so mvl well closely followed behind by
jan but also fabiano and jeffrey right
with the striking distance
and this round is incredibly incredibly
packed with uh with games
between yeah we have one playing four
no no we have one playing three one
playing three and two playing four in
this round yeah exactly huge round and
we also have five playing six actually
bobby is playing against jeffrey in a
very very important match-ups uh so yeah
all of this
the entire round is full of very very
impactful uh impactful games so
hard to pick one but i think we have to
pick the the the old french battle there
at the top exactly absolutely once again
history of potentially being made before
our eyes here
in terms of getting 2 900 2900 yes
absolutely wouldn't it be fun yeah i
mean i mean in a way
after nobody getting there for years and
years and years if both ali reza and
hikar win in this round we will have two
of them yeah that's ridiculous there
will be something yeah there will be
that will extrude two of them getting to
training 100. oh
and this round yes
at the same time
wow it really is yeah we're entering the
hollowed portals of 2900
damn and alireza is going to be uh quite
ahead of hikaru by 1.2
points or something
yeah that's a massive massive margin
let's just remind our viewers earlier in
today's event uh hikaru
with a win could have pierced the 2900
barrier and prior to that game he missed
it by 0.6 exactly and he just failed at
that moment
hikaru is in a very strange position
because he came into today's uh action
uh hoping that lots of people would
knock
uh farouja off his perch now he's
rooting for him like
exactly
knock them all out
out of the way for me please
how would you assess peter
nepo's results
i think he'll be somewhat disappointed i
think he is
uh generally uh he's not shown his best
play
he's standing in the in the in the
uh in the tournaments is not horrible uh
you know we have two people who were are
we actually going to see a repetition of
that no no this is a this is a game this
is not the i mean this is not the
my my choice right of game although they
are playing
okay knight c3 and the pause which is
maybe a good sign because there's plenty
of very very forcing draws in these
positions as well but
uh
the fact that
the
the extremely quick repetition of theory
somewhat stopped is a good sign there
should be seven yeah people still play
bishop c7 but i always felt that this
was magnus magnus's choice against igara
nakamura 97 yeah d4565 bishop before
this this line is extremely well known
as and it's really supposed to be
nothing at all
but white very occasionally does win
some games in it and by the way hikaru
has the option and the opportunity to
cross 2 900 against the king's cabin
against the king's gate is the king's
game
that's interesting okay
uh by the way peter you seem to
have i felt this myself
yeah no this is a very very well known
line in the in the in berlin there
there's been a bunch of games i had this
against a bit of vessel in topolof in
moscow canada in 2016. 2016. yeah
already there it was reasonably well
known just not to me i remember i had to
work it all out at the board but yeah
people knew uh i believe with correct
play is supposed to be very very equal
but there have been some games recently
where black made some slight
inaccuracies and actually failed to
equalize
it looks a bit strange with you know
such little material left on the board
and white having the isolani but the
bishop on c4 is just so much more active
than the bishop on d7 that it's always
black who wants to equalize here but
he should he should he should yeah
i think i think generally yeah you do
you do equalize in these types of
positions
bishop e6
uh a very very long-winded theoretical
battle going on here christian just any
uh in this penultimate game we've got so
many keys
maybe you've watched the king's gambit
because nepal seems to be doing quite
well yeah and apple got a very decent
position out of the opening there where
is that game just a second 39
39 yeah
that's very dry
with a lot more interest uh big fight
for second third here yeah any king's
gambit if you forgive me i'm just gonna
it was
really really weird oops sorry really
weird move order in the beginning it
wasn't i just
more than curious queen gambit should be
five knight bd7 a move i don't know
particularly well and then this b2 very
clever idea dropping it back to avoid
getting healed by c76 now yes if i
bishops before i expected this i think
this is very attractive for white
uh you would like to play knight of
eight bush b6 but knight ninety-five i
think we are just in time to play knight
g5 and actually win some material and if
you play h6 here to stop knight g5 even
queen b3 is annoying 92 is annoying
there's a bunch of things how do you win
material after knight g596 uh well i
take everything and take on the f4 so
you take with the bishop first
well knight f8 knight g5 g596 i thought
knight takes is also fine why not
knight takes bishop takes bishop takes
rook takes i take on a four i mean it's
not much black actually gets it
yeah there's definitely compensation but
why this very much i think in the
driver's seat there absolutely upper
pawn and i mean every every end game
probably is winning
and what did you discuss that was wrong
with h7h6 i think knight v2 probably is
the most annoying thing about it
provoking g5 i mean although you might
actually want to play h6 and g5 we'll
see i mean h6 knight g4 by hikaru this
is this looks very very loose
yeah and uh they they did draw that
uh a pause before 2 900. yeah hicaro is
not hitting 2900 no i like it
yeah alireza will actually lose some
points with this draw it's he's so high
rated that it will cost him like three
points or whatever
uh here i would like to play h3 but yeah
uh this maybe is even stronger queen b3
unless rook b8 is playable but rook b8
looks very dodgy the point here is that
i want to provoke a rook move i guess
rookie 7 and then i will play h3
and
because your queen is i very much want
to invite you to play 9300 take with the
pawn
opening up my f1 rook and then all of
those famous famous famous bronze
game so yeah i can start with rook b8
after uh yeah start with b8 i think is
what will what will happen yeah for sure
you you can't keep the the queen on b3
but then you also have ideas of queen a4
queen take c6 so if you cannot get
enough compensation for that pawn that's
a significant part yes but because white
has provoked the rook to e7 knight g5 95
is also quite definitely
like you you're worried like i would be
very worried i blundered the knight
takes c5 like knight g5 knight c5 dc5
queen d4 is just
small third mate pretty much noelle rook
f1 is covered the phone is covered yeah
okay not smothered right
so close still still scary though
still scary yeah and by the way guys
i did win some raiding points uh he won
raising points yes
because he started yeah he started the
the started under 2800 guys
but it's 28.95 now he won he won
and right now he's sitting on exactly
100 rating points again yeah okay wow he
heard us
congratulations to ali he realized it's
unacceptable that he's not winning 100.
yeah yeah we're cheering a remarkable
result witnessing history if you will
h2h3 and the poor
rook be where it was
before that's the issue as uh christian
absolutely correctly pointed out i i
still think we do that i i don't think
we're going to yeah
knight g5
yes
oh pardon me 93 is a tempo against the
queen
he's played queen a4 takes and f takes
yeah this is a very sharp position
because if you take on six you actually
revive the bishop on c8 it will go to b7
and b7 is a very good square yeah right
but i go back and i have c6 coming so
you have to stop me somehow you have to
do it fast yeah it's a it's a very very
unclear position uh i think in blitz
you start getting the feeling that it's
maybe easier to play with black
because uh you've shared your queen
takes a second you're weakness yeah
you've shared your weaknesses and now
you are the side i don't know it's a
very
very weird position i keep on going back
and forth on what i think about it yeah
you probably have to kind of close your
eyes and take on c6 because nothing else
appears to be doing the trick if you
allow let's say knight f6 black just
stabilizes he's taking so he's taking
bishop b7 a4 bishop g3 played very very
quickly by instantly c6 is met by knight
b6 so yeah that's and he wants this
bishop on f2 which is very very sensible
it's a
fantastic square for the bishop
and by the way in the battle for the
third position fabiano seems to be doing
quite well with the black pieces against
jeffrey sean
thank you for that uh queen c yeah i
think
jan is very very happily offering this
exchange like rook of two will be met by
take stakes instantly i would play
knight f6 here with black if it's
playable the big question is do am i
losing to knight g5
and then
the knight g5 yeah i'm guessing not i'm
guessing i've always got bishop f2 which
is a and young very explicit 65 using uh
using the fact that he will have bins
available to him if that pawn gets
picked up also knight g5 will be but the
quality iii is so annoying
true that but if i get a pawn on c6
point my point is yes i know i want to
take on d5 and i think
the existence of the resource of e3 2 in
all of those positions
will be crucially very very crucial yes
but 95 for given rook g7 it's very
difficult i think for black to go for
that position it looks like if you
miscalculate it you're done right
you're just done but maybe there is no
better choice because allowing c6 you're
also kind of done yeah exactly
we should be fine
immediately ship f2 so you can play
knight
i don't know why that was crucial why
not rook d1 yeah i don't know why we
didn't start with d1 this is very
confusing to me
i don't like this and now knight f6 can
be played next move i think this was
just a mistake i think though yeah i
agree i think there's no this was this
was just a mistake you have to start
with
d7 and then go from so he's gone rook f2
yeah he had to because allowing knight
of six and yeah i mean this is still a
game because f7 is weak and uh there's a
lot of ducts still up in the air but
knight f6 or knight c4 also if i managed
to go b4 b5 is then 93 might have seven
i think so i think length of six is what
you play here or h6 if you can which he
did he did h6 rook d1
this is a very very confusing position
the one i think we can take
unfortunately like rook d1 hg 95 from d7
is very strong
rook t1 hg
i think we might have to take with the
bishop and that's something i would hate
to do
truly i think hikaru is now sort of in
control i mean it's not dead lost for
white or anything like that but hikar i
think is in control now
yeah not playing roxy one there is
extremely extremely strange boy but yeah
very it was just the move that you're
you're really kind of supposed to be
making with your with your hand
he does it in this order yeah he wants
to go hd rock d5 in this version yeah
and then
i have have compensation but
uh yeah black is completely fine you can
go hd and then rook d7 which i think is
at least fine for black
has he done that he probably is supposed
to get and then now i mean giving up the
g5 pawn seems unnecessary i think i'm
playing rook g7
and then the question is what do we do
with white we have queen f5 if we want
we have
take stakes c6 maybe if we want
but it's always going to be slightly
better for black at the very least
because the
our opponent is still on b2 it's not
going to be fine exactly 75 is not that
important that's the that's the issue
yep
uh you mentioned queen f5 peter queen f5
playable but i don't think it does
enough i think even they take stake
screen f6 is playable from like
wait a minute are you sure about that
that's a c6 pawn isn't it yeah well it's
not running with the bishop on d5 king
of six king of king of fate can you say
if you're yeah if you're in time to
block with the king in the meantime i
think uh shaq has already beaten sam
shanklin yeah it's not it's not very
relevant to our tournament standings and
everything but uh
fabi versus fabiano is just about to win
his game against jeffrey rook d6 that
was a nice little
uh
move there because why wouldn't you
running out of good ideas i'm not sure
how good it is i can even take i have
rook h6 or queen h6 in the end no i was
just going to
trade the c5 pawn for the f7 pawn and
then maybe even a7 as well it goes queen
queen is seven he continues yeah this is
uh this is going a bit off the rails for
uh for yanya all of these positions
but the king of juventus so very unsafe
here you're you are like hoping to
survive here you're
yeah
yeah c6 played you can take once again
if you want um you can also yeah play
play some kind of a blockading move like
queen c7 jan is also down to nine seven
yeah not very many seconds bishop to
yeah and your bishop is sort of standing
on air right right right right it's not
anchored yeah it's not yeah he wants to
yeah queen of five and now he wants to
put maybe maybe in some positions he
will put it on f3 and with the bishop
103 he will start feeling better about
life because at least we've protected
our stuff and um but then he will get
pushed by back by g7 g6
it's it's still yeah it's still very
unpleasant for uh
for for yan
exactly but at least we control the
entrance squares like diwali is never
going to be available for the roku
by the way huge result for our third
place
as fabi did win his game against jeffrey
yes
that's obviously a very very very good
result for for fabiano there yeah and
this one yeah
hikaru is also down to not not a lot of
time and he he repeats once
i mean for hikaru draw is probably fine
in this game i i mean he would like to
get to 20 2900 but apart from that one
little bit of you know motivation right
draw in terms of a tournament result
like drawing this game is completely
fine he is on very very
uh before
four is hanging that's a pawn
no you can't play bishop b7 i've got oh
yeah covered that is fair yeah that is
fair okay bishop yeah okay
whoa wrong
seven though queen f2 c7 and it's still
not over guys yeah it's still all over
somewhat shockingly rook b8 trying to go
to b1 yeah queen c2 by
yeah queen of two now
he's trying to warm his way
but then queen g3 and we trade a for c
right queen takes a six now
takes c7 and we can the same issues as
before yeah queen on
the h2 diagonal followed by rook to the
first round like it's over yeah he will
win yeah he will win this position now
so hikar actually gets there maybe king
g1 right king g1 and bishop we can take
on a4 as well if we want which will
probably we do want
come on hikaru queen a1
yeah c6 is also completely fine yeah
why are we keeping ourselves pinned
because he was afraid he wants to keep
the queens on the board for some reason
yeah
now he's got the setup that he wants
queen f6 you can go if you want to yeah
i mean giving mate is preferable but uh
yeah but roxy honestly the sun game is
not as it's not as lost as all that i i
think i would actually be going for that
end game compared to eventually getting
mated with the queens on the board
don't don't grab your queen hicaro
f6 oh yeah but i think win of two is
coming in so he has actually won the
bishop on c1 on f1 this is why i mean i
would actually uh why i'm saying i would
actually have traded the queens because
without without the queen trade you will
just end up getting mated by queen f2 by
losing and i think
is 2900 yeah this is this is our 2900 uh
uh history making yes
history just made are we sure that
nobody else passed we are not sure we're
not sure
i don't know if it's i'm sure should be
possible i feel it was in the first year
when it was introduced the rating system
for the rapid and blitz i think somebody
with this humongous k pass 2 900 in the
live rating list
in fact
talk about i mean there's tom
to
uh blow
that four are hyperbole away yeah
we were way out has already passed 2900
in the past as have three other players
i won't mention them
we were waiting i'm telling you we need
the diamond membership guys yes
one of us is going to have to deep
dig into our wallets and then pay
membership with this victory hikaru i
think secures second but the fight for
third is somewhat unclear because i
think it's fabiano and mvl right now i
think it's a shootout yeah
wow
um
okay i want to just say the last 30 40
moves there by hikaru uh showed
remarkable judgment really yeah i think
i think that was a very very nicely
played game but yeah you have to go back
to that moment where you like
how do you not play rogue people on
there right just yeah we were just so
confused by knight g5 i believe it was
right just right here which was played
so fast oh yeah and played instantly i
mean
i mean if if it's white to play white
slamming down
c5 c6 so the whole point is
would you be brave enough to essay
knight takes d5 rook d1
i think he realized that once he allows
rook d7 knight g5 will no longer be
available so he thought this is the last
time you i can play knight g5 and okay
he so badly wanted to get knight g5 in
that he that sort of clouded his
judgment
but yeah i think you you have to uh play
rook divine and then search for
something here perhaps queen of five is
strong perhaps something else but
um
yeah i'm curious exactly what the answer
is because i've been i've been trying to
uh to math it out
and failing
but he didn't do that and he said he
went for knight g5 and after the mission
is
instantly worse yeah
it's it's bad news uh again very here
are our current standings after the
penultimate round
one round left peter yeah alireza on 25
points he's finally made a second draw
of the day meaning that he can't get to
26 and a half but he can still get to 26
out of 36 hikaru in clear second and
securing the second place and the thirty
thousand dollar prize that goes with it
that goes with it and then uh maxima
shiragapu is having a horrendous blitz
tournament that's seven and a half
points in the blitz tournament wow
but he's done so well he's done so well
in the rapid that right this is still
enough for
clear third fabio now is in clear fourth
which is the franchise for uh points
sorry it's not going to be enough for
him to overtake wesley but it's a good
result of course and then yanipan mishi
and shakira mijero won 17 and a half
which is actually 50
and we are going to be back with the
final round don't go away we'll see you
on the other side of our brick
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the final round of the
2092 saint louis rapid and blitz and we
have our first two finishers with
alireza's absolutely dominant
performance letting him the first place
and the forty thousand dollars and
hikaru nakamura securing second with
round to spare as well exactly the
defending champion playing well enough
in the blitz but it was that uh rapids
that put him off and here it is our
current standings with one round to play
peter
uh as as we've said uh aleris on 25
kikar on 20. those are unassailable
right uh and then we have a fight for
third between uh probably just mvl and
fabio at this point and we all playing
uh sam franklin with the black pieces
and fabiano carolina white against
jacques
who could actually leave that's a big
one that's a big one yeah let's take a
look at the pairings in fact
as you mentioned that fabi versus shaq
and the other one that you mentioned
shanklin versus mbl yeah but in terms of
ours like shahriar actually has a chance
of perhaps even catching a podium finish
if he bits if he beats fabiano he
overtakes fabiano and if nbl loses he
actually catches up to mvl so he could
be in a tie for third
if he wins against fabio with the black
pieces now yandy punish is also a little
bit in the mix there
if he beats the one with black and uh
the others and the results
break his way dominguez can also catch
up with shanklin potentially
[Music]
i'm not holding my breath
moment of silence
silence indeed christian
you see christian masters are very
insightful you're more insightful than
you'd even care about okay okay i get it
i get it i get it
uh but this game uh
very very uh crucial uh for the podium
finish and i don't think we've seen any
of these players actually
not a lot we've seen a bit but not not a
lot today in the middle of the game
definitely not from the start ali reza
and hikaru have really stolen the show
where the blitz has been concerned and
we're trying to play catch up you know
feel feeling bad
that
fabi hasn't gotten enough air time and
shack fans as well
so we're making up for it peter
absolutely we're providing a public
service exactly exactly very valuable
public service
now one of the things is in blitz these
pieces are absolutely absolutely
gorgeous in fact they're such beautiful
sets
i would be loath
to be using them
for a blitz
competition because of the fear that i
break
yeah they're not easily breakable but
that is true they do slide very nicely
across the board we have seen some very
questionable piece placements towards
the you know when your clock runs down
the single digits you're
you know you
somewhere between g8 and g9
uh pieces of land catalan by fabi here
uh
i assume over the course of his career
played absolutely everything under the
sun against the catalan from open to
closed and stops in between he has to
play for a win though he needs to play
for a win yes i assume he's not going to
go for the main lines draw does
absolutely nothing for him in terms of
fighting for
a third in this tournament so yeah do
you think c4 okay with the maybe the b5
oops
with b5 ideas no still there's a lot of
ways to play in this position to keep
some absolutely on the board
it's a blitz game anyway we shouldn't
really be overselling the fact that
you're sort of allowed to play some
openings but not the others it's so it's
not really true and this actually is one
of the sharper lines because after b6 i
think b okay
probably didn't play 95 but i believe
you could play 95 and then play becomes
very very uh chaotic because you
generally sacrifice that exchange on the
e8 for some pieces
after
95 and so on yeah i see
four bishops bishop g5 yeah
response
this looks very very cosy for black to
be honest i
normally when i have the pawns on a6 and
b5 the idea of getting in c5 is a lot
more difficult with the pawn on b6 i'm a
bit surprised by h6 honestly because i
think we generally would like to be
taking on f6 with the knight
and why aren't we starting with knight
bd7 and making sure that we have that
option later is
a mystery yeah and it will remain a
mystery it will
for example right now if you go c5 i
have a feeling that i might have the
move e5 e5 followed by the b7 d5 seems
to work tactically and then yeah you're
you're running into somewhat there then
dangerous territory
you could consider
but this is play on one goal yes it's
very nice for white yeah quincy three
queen f6 and then we just don't trade
queens we choose a way to keep the
queens on the board queen e3 i assume is
the most natural movie i don't think i
care very much about the b2 pawn
i would be very very
happy to just give it up for a couple of
things uh let me play the devil's
advocate for a moment queen c3 queen f6
also he hasn't taken on c3 i think he's
looking at moves like rook 81
immediately trying to play for a much
more allowance oh
yes but with the with the pin along the
g file there's all kinds of 95 things
you have to calculate and so on okay i
don't know if it works it's a very
committal decision if you don't know the
answer which i assume he doesn't because
such a kind of a rare niche position
yeah he's gone okay do you wanna i like
yeah i think it's like you played in
proper spirit at least but of the
position
okay uh again the devil's advocate in me
uh
asked the salient question can't i take
upon peter
c3 takes b2 check
on g4 or c3 g4
yeah g4 looks like the right square and
i have to king h7 though i thought you
have to play king h8 and then i want to
play queen f4 and then start threatening
knight e5 besides but king h7 i cannot
play yeah we okay rook c8 is uh similar
but now i just got b2 takes c3 and i
think i'm reasonably happy with the
outcomes because very much so there is
no pawn on b2 right the queen has been
delayed on d8 meaning that queen as well
as on f6 yeah is there anything to be
said about queen h5 first or queen to f4
first
yes in both cases i i was in 95 so i was
looking at
that as well actually yeah yeah that
that that is also an option
but i think he took on c3 yeah i think
it takes you three i mean the opposition
is good enough there i don't i think
you're reasonably happy with it anyway
so
why uh overthink it perhaps is the the
reasoning here queen e7 feels absolutely
required we need to unpin ourselves if
we if we don't unfeed ourselves here
with black it feels like the game might
be over very very soon and since we will
have we receiving moves right now maybe
we can see the bird's eye view uh it
doesn't seem like um
yeah we're receiving moves right now
but uh you mean no move since king h8
yeah i think that xc3 has been played
but neither it was it's not updating so
perhaps uh perhaps a full screen uh full
screen of the board yeah so
by the way a queen d4 check
queen pardon me knight f6
queen f4 yeah the king is actually on h7
not h8 and he played 27 the which fight
he replied with queen a4 which is
uh a kind of a choice f4 first
seven and now queen to eight okay so
what had happened after rook c a peter
oh g4 h8 bc no it was king h7 king h8 i
think uh
okay this position doesn't matter how we
get there this is the position yeah yeah
well it was just the uh
the board updating the board okay fair
enough and by the way two minutes only
for mamed
almost four minutes it's difficult
choices maybe you take one of three i
take on that three i want to get rid of
that knight
six blade uh he is inviting to take say
seven i
don't know why he likes it so much but
yeah seven looks eminently playable give
it to me yes quincy seven maybe as a
republican seven i can go knight g5 in
the worst case right yeah but i win the
opponent's e3 in the end that's fine for
black actually the policy iii is hanging
which is very relevant that makes sense
yeah because
and the reason we're playing queen c7
there is that after queen a7 if you
start by rook takes e3 95 seems painful
even there rook c7 is not losing on the
spot but yeah
yeah i'm pretty sure q7 was always
always going to be the plan here and now
fabi needs to find a good way to uh to
continue because uh
rook a8 is not actually threatening to
win the queen we always have the backup
of knight g5 check but
uh you do have to address
but maybe that's the idea that's there's
no threat in the position and i can
maybe defend the pawn on c3 with root d3
but then okay in the end i will take on
a2 right
after all the trades i will win the aids
upon then and it's still very very level
yeah it's it's interesting to me that
fabi didn't try to to achieve something
on the king side he i thought he had a
promising a promising position to try
some i don't know rook lift so there are
even some sacrificial ideas there which
seemed to me like they had
some worth but
he went with a very conservative option
he did indeed
i'm just looking at queen a3 queen c3
queenies in the meantime we're not
switching but just just to update our
viewers mvl has a solid position against
sam shanklin but a position which i
think is going to be quite difficult for
him to win okay uh which means that
a bunch of people potentially could
catch up or perhaps even overtake him
well that was very prophylactic move
team g7 just saying that uh i don't want
to be discovered yet and the situation
with the pawn on b6 against spawns on a2
and c3 you get in a lot of openings
including my beloved grunfeld but i was
about to say yeah
only one opening i'm aware of the groom
held or you'd get maybe you know i think
i think the names are different there's
a bunch of these where basically the
point is the pressure against those two
weaknesses yeah rook a8 rook fc-8 uh
you just start playing in those against
those two pawns and you generally are
okay but the the the difference here of
course is that position of the king on
g7 normally your structure on the kick
on the king's side is
entirely unspoiled right meaning that
you don't have to worry about the king's
side very much here uh he obviously has
to pay attention i very much like quincy
five because
he is saying you would like to play c4
but currently you cannot because rook a3
will
uh put a lot of pressure on your setup
it doesn't actually win the piece
because queen d1 exists but at least it
wins the pawn on nature exactly rook a3
yeah very big threat
uh
nice initiative for a pawn uh full
compensation no question very very
picturesque draw uh in the game uh our
onion nippon nishi we we will show that
game later like the final position is
extremely beautiful to look at but we
have
live games to talk about so
the time will come for that rook b1 on
the board something to be said for
bishop e4 no queen b3 queen b6 sorry
yeah those end games are actually
generally speaking like if you play this
before here queen b6 you take on b6 take
on a2
uh they're not that bad very often
they're quite holdable but wow uh yeah
he's gone bishop d5 and then queen takes
c3 a more concrete version of similar
attacking the 993 and obviously yeah
we're picking up the pawn only two it
seems like it will be difficult for fabi
to
get much of anywhere queen a3 played
yeah the pawn on 82 is falling if you if
we can't mount some kind of an immediate
attack against the black king we're just
not going to be better
exactly rook fb8 also i wanted to say i
wanted to play knight d4 right now but
after rfb8 it gets a bit awkward yeah
who do you like and why he's gone 95
which is a much better square edge i
like 95 a lot more but i think just
taking on g2 and taking on a2 and then
bringing the queen back wide to the g5
square is probably just completely fine
agreed yeah i think this is what he is
going to go for here takes on g2 i don't
think we have any intermediate moves
here
and yeah and by the way just to give you
an update hikaru is winning his game
against jeffrey sean
meaning that jeffrey will not be
finishing on the pedestal nicaragua is
already second and is in in no trouble
whatsoever also
is looking really good again yeah and
this will be this will be a draw now i
don't think queen d5 i don't think shaq
is much stronger than queen d5 check but
after 25 check the game is not really
very exciting anymore
so what are we watching looking for yeah
i guess we're watching the oh okay okay
for just 53
i don't think i don't think this is much
of anything at all frankly
the problem is queen d5 is coming as
well yeah
should we see history yeah let's let's
actually let's actually
watch the
lap of honor there by alireza against
linear linearities and you've won a
bunch of games in a row but he's
probably not winning this one this looks
like a very very suspect position for
for lanier even though it's not
immediately obvious how you so uh has an
exchange in hand yes but this position
is full of
gaping holes
and
not to mention also the hp5 i think
after rg6 the idea is to play bishop d5
check but after king of fate i still
don't know what the solution is there
must be a solution though because uh you
feel
clearly
under through g6 and king of faith
on the other hand if there's no
immediate mate let's go queen h5
bishop take c5 just through g6 i guess
yeah yeah he's done it he's done it yeah
there is no choice because rook takes g5
queen f7
is mate so yeah you have to go for this
but it continues being very very bad so
the king is weak the b6 is also falling
meaning that the knight on a4 is about
to rejoin five seconds
i think we start with knight b6 even
though there's maybe even queen f5 is
untapped yeah i think i think we start
with 96 and now queen g8 queen f7 queen
e6 is made yeah now with the g7 pawn go
d7 square gone we just get mated very
nice yeah
wow wow
yeah 26 out of 36 i'm guessing this is
equal second uh in the uh list of
overall best performances in the gct
events i think i've seen 22 draws i
think i've seen 26 uh
points on the list of best ever but i
mean eight from nine and the l did it
once no i mean i mean overall yeah he's
today's result of eight out of nine
sorry yeah
we they kind of got lost
right
actually
sam's versus mvl is a very interesting
end game whoa
i i've paused right
here yeah
what is this well he's currently he
carries a piece up but he is struggling
to put it to bed i mean he will win but
for for the time being this is a kind of
a weird position where
okay let's go to her so he needs to find
he needs to find a way to yeah but i
think g4 will actually conclude the game
because once we create the threat of g4
g5
there's going to be
no way to defend i think we just go g5
here i mean by the way guys karana is
low right now ah yeah there's bishop
city check there
fabi is losing khabib is losing right
now or at least he's worse
oof maybe not anymore things are
changing with every single move and we
do have a handshake as jeffrey
uh
loses to yeah
managed to play himself in very very
serious trouble uh
in that game
somehow still alive uh and yeah nobody
has any time rookie six checking f7 you
have to go back
two again again sometime on the clock
but yeah weirdly there is no mate and
the king of seven is kind of well he
goes for it wow
well he has to go forward i assume we
have we have a perpetual now this will
now just be a draw i could quincy
an illegal move as well
oh shakriar it makes another illegal
move and it's well that's why
very important results right third place
fabiano catches mvl who drew his game
and they're going to split they're going
to share the third the grand chess tour
points yes
what did we just that was
wow shaq just lost his head at the very
end they did not need to do that yeah
that was sorry
and
yeah let's take a look at the napo draw
yeah that was a very very stunning final
position and and neville also went for a
flourish there uh you will see rook
givenchy giving up this rook and i think
he immediately yeah i mean he gave a
couple of checks like this
he's sitting there grinning
perhaps
double checking if maybe there is mate
but there is no mate right just to be
sure though and is he smiling yeah he
sees queen e1 he starts laughing
no i mean he these guys they they do
love the game they play you know yeah
and lucky is going to check if knight
takes f3 does anything but unfortunately
for him the g8 square is covered
otherwise rook g8 after takes takes
would have been made in one but there's
this queen on h7 which is doing
something and now and now it's coming
yeah it's so it's a very very cute thing
to do yeah let's go
let's go
[Laughter]
double check
double check nice check and a double
check
right
i'm not sure i'm not sure what they're
trying to tell because you can say to
each other it's a very very enjoyable
continued
culmination of that game
well done and that concludes the
tournament it certainly does but uh i
need a recap because again such an
eventful round christian it's just
amazing
very difficult i think we've actually
covered almost everything uh
the one game that almost got no coverage
at all was the game between sam
shankland and mvl but everything else
we've shown our viewers
but uh
enough of this uh let's jump to
christian who is going to
interview our champion christian alireza
first of all congratulations what a
dominating performance you came uh to st
luis you said this is a dream for you to
play in st louis not only that you
fulfilled that dream but in such a
tremendous fashion describe to us your
uh feelings right now
yeah actually um
i could reveal a secret it was my
promise for a long time that if i come
to san diego's i win my first tournament
so
i managed to did you make that promise
to myself
for a long time so
now it's really remarkable this um chess
club i'm really in love with this chess
club
i think everything is in a
good
manner and i'm really happy to be here
we saw you pensive in between rounds you
were thinking not necessarily speaking
to other players were you just like
simply focused were you trying to be in
the moment
yeah i think um
okay the talking that they were doing it
was also not in a
not very important in the
subject i was not really interested in
so
um i'll see also i think hikora was not
talking to everybody so yeah i think
keeping focus is important so
at least for me so yeah
how important uh was it for your mom to
be here with you in st louis as well as
your brother it felt like they kept you
grounded could you describe that yeah my
whole family is here my father brother
mother everybody's here
um
yeah i always travel with them during
the tournaments so
i'm really grateful for them to be here
always with me it's very important i
think
and yeah i'm very thankful
the first time uh being a full-time
player in the grand chess tour and you
already win
an event what does that mean to you yeah
it means a lot of course
it's a very tough tournament
i think this rapidem blitz was the
strongest because the others they were
many few wild cards that were not in
very high rated so
i'm happy to win this one but of course
still there is stingfield cup so
were you aware by uh the fact that with
this last victory you passed twenty nine
hundred on the live waiting list were
you keeping in touch yeah it was a very
but the sad thing is that i'm not number
one
imagine the world that you're in 2900
and you're not number one it's well
hikaru won a lot of games as well yes i
thought he could shoot his rating
collapsed during in the middle because
he lost two three games but
i guess his rating was very high so
he came back as well still what an
impressive uh performance ali reza
congratulations guys any questions yeah
i wanted to champion from behind the
wall i want to maybe ask alireza to
settle this for us if you wanted if you
had to choose between
i don't know i'm choosing two which i
think are probably in the running there
uh which one means more to you this one
or the grand swiss
ah
okay um it's very different because
grand swiss was a 20 days event and it
was during quarantine so that was very
important for me also here i think for
now this is more important for me than
grants is because
the cycle of candidates is not the
ideal base so i think this this one
means a lot to me actually maybe this
one more even than currencies
yasser any follow-up questions i just
want to say our deepest congratulations
we you thrilled us throughout and uh
you're very deserving champion olivier
is a very good luck to you in the sink
field cup we'll be watching well played
thanks sir congratulations ali reza you
are the champion of the st louis rapid
and blitz congratulations
once more peter the final final final
standings if you please and there you
have it uh alireza wins the tournament
wins forty thousand dollars wins the
thirteen uh branches four points right
hikaru in clear second there wild cards
are no crunchy store points for him uh
30 grand and then a type of third
between fabian mbl both get seven and a
half points
uh and both get twenty two point five
thousand dollars and i think levon with
his three and a half actually ties
wesley wesley whereas mvl will and emile
will definitely overtake him as will uh
alireza and thank you just be right
behind wesley mbl is actually in clear
first now and vl will be on 26 and a
half and already will be on 25 and a
half if i believe right
and let's jump back to
christian who is with hikaru hikaru an
inspiring performance in the blitz
section nevertheless i see you a bit
disappointed describe to us uh your
feelings right now i'm disappointed
i mean i could hardly be happier
honestly i mean i didn't show it for
three days and then i at least tried to
remember how to play chess the last two
days so
um i mean with the way alireza played
throughout the tournament obviously very
deserving winner um and in particular i
mean the way that he played today at
least or it was never realistic like i
can look at my tournament and be unhappy
about maybe two of the games in the
rapid and i think i should have drawn
instead of losing but it still wouldn't
have made a difference so it's really
hard to be unhappy um you know i think
i'm actually quite happy with the way i
played after these two uh these two
unfortunate losses today and just just
won a couple games at the end so yeah
second place pretty good when did you
feel like you're regaining your mojo at
the beginning of the blitz section which
one was the precise moment i mean
probably it was well i think for the
blitz it was the first two games both
days i mean yesterday i had the two
whites and i kind of after this game
against fabiana which i lost in the rap
but i just wanted to play chess there's
really nothing else in my head at that
time at that moment um
and i won that game i won against 11 the
rest of the day kind of flowed today was
i mean much different i i i felt like i
probably should have made a draw against
alireza in this third round game after
the second game which was really a very
tilting loss that i had against lavon
but i figured okay i should probably try
um and obviously that didn't go well but
then i was able to stabilize pretty
quickly in the following game against uh
sam i think it was so overall i mean i
can't really be that unhappy i wish i
had played better in the rapid but i
don't think that the overall result was
in doubt so after being last three days
to finish in second
can't be better really couldn't ask for
more hikari you have a legion of fans
behind you any words for them and what's
next for you um well i mean i think i i
showed i could play chess i think a lot
of people after three days were saying i
should like go back into retirement or
things like this especially my good good
friends over on that famous reddit uh
right it's that subreddit so um yeah i
mean uh in terms of upcoming tournaments
i don't have a lot i actually felt that
probably it was a big mistake that i
didn't really get any time off before
playing here i mean i played this rapid
chess championship which was four days
in a row um against other top players
then i played this like 960 title
tuesday rainy kings i mean i played
seven days in a row before this event
and i think that was uh probably too
much overall uh
and then moving forward
i mean i go back to streaming
next tournament that i know i'm playing
is a 960 here in st louis in a couple of
weeks and then
probably uh there's this tata steel
event at the end of november i believe
it isn't if there's a world raptor but
it's probably that but yeah a couple of
tournaments but i get to go back to my
real job so it's all good
congratulations uh hikaru always a
pleasure to have you here in st louis
thank you our congratulations as well
hikaru and
let's take a look at the gct standings
with the inclusion of the rapid and
blitz peter the honors there you have it
uh mvl in the lead both in terms of
points and in terms of money earned
uh followed by alireza feroza after his
very very convincing win here uh
in clear second and then a tie for third
fourth between lebron iranian and uh
wesley so all to play for in the
singfield cup uh which of course will
also see the uh the return to the fault
of none other than magnus carlsen so uh
perhaps some points will be allocated
there but uh still a very very tight uh
fight for the top three spots on the
tour i have a feeling that baby is a
little sore that
uh
ikaro took away 10 grand chest door
points there but fabi is with
christian
fabiano you surge through the rankings
in that final stretch how did you
approach this funny day of blitz
well i mean
before today i didn't really have any
ambitions for anything first place was
out
second place was out you know i mean
pretty much any
hope of like a really successful
tournament but um
yeah i mean i'm always a bit embarrassed
with how it happened at the end because
of course i should have lost that last
game
uh i did play one really good game that
i'm proud of against jeffrey and at
least i think it was very good that was
my feeling
um which is nice that's that's at least
one nice uh and yeah i got lucky at the
end which is which is also good
would you pinpoint that game as the
moment when you felt like you could be
playing for like third position and
actually that would be a final good
score
no i i was trying i mean i thought i
could fight for fourth i i didn't think
that i would be able to share third but
fourth seemed
relatively doable at some point
very good and how would you assess your
performance so far and how do you feel
before the start of the sinful cup
well pretty pretty lousy play but uh the
result was better than my play and um
and yeah i ended on a high note so i
have the positive emotions from the good
last day well just a couple of days to
get some rest we'll see you at the sink
field cup congratulations thank you fabi
a quick question for you the sinfield
cup of course
is the home of one of your greatest if
not greatest results ever
your thoughts looking forward to the
final event
of the grand chess tour how are you
going to handle it
well there's a lot on the line i mean
the tournament itself uh all the best
players in the world but also the
i i have still have some shot at like a
decent overall uh grand chess tour
standing like maybe third is within
reach now um because the results
went my way in this tournament i mean
overall um
uh so yeah uh i mean today was very
important for my fight for
for let's say third or or or maybe
second or something like that in the
grand chester if i have a very good
syncfield cup especially because you
finished tied with maxim was also very
close to the top yeah yeah this is a
great result for maxime of course it's
um
he he was basically not connect with a
bunch of players and now he's separated
somewhat from them
fabiano congratulations we'll see you in
a couple of days thank you
absolutely our congratulations as well
uh our predictions uh how good oh pardon
me are we a reminder that magnus rejoins
the tour uh for the singfield cup and
that's starting september 2nd
very soon and as for predictions uh
yeah some some heavy people some uh
try to yeah triumphant return right so
who's paying
well i mean ali reza wins the tournament
with four rounds to spare what do you
say but well done young man
uh final thoughts a christian of this
rapid and blitz well it was just a
fantastic event filled with drills and
spills so many interesting games i have
to say uh my students at the university
that i coach have a training today one
of my students is uh conducting that
training and i sent them a bunch of
positions from this tournament so
definitely a lot of content a lot of
great games and it was a pleasure to do
commentary with two legends such as
yourself so well that's that for me that
was a very convincing sneaker
sorry
allergies
kristen sorry to say we'll be uh
losing you uh alejandro will be uh
taking your spot for this
we're missing you already i will be back
for uh the champions showdown chess uh
960. threats that's all we need
i'll see you in a couple of weeks guys
all right thank you very much chris
thanks everyone it's really really
wonderful it was a blast i hope you
enjoyed our coverage uh we're taking a
small break but we'll be back on on
friday with the first round of the
sinful cup which is a fantastic
fantastic event magnus is playing all of
these guys are playing i just wanted to
say really peter i think you're
wonderful you're a really really great
commentator as well wonderful to call
the action with you
i would return the favor but
all of this goes without saying well 11
comes to you so i don't uh thank you
everyone for joining you for joining us
tonight there will be the uh closing
ceremony and then the singfill cup i
hope you
tune in see you then
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited